check one two check one and a two and a
check check check I go back
I am already throw Papa lets out the window
this is definitely a Papa was his fault
the hardware is also shot so I had to adjust
my balance levels
so it has two problems but
yeah I have my like at the modify my ass out
the cable in pretty sure it's the it's the
jackets the front headphone jack that's got
a problem
which is a pain in the ass
and I don't know how many of you been
watching this but every time like after
about a after about a day with Papa less all
of these menu items disappear you can't read
any of the text on here at all it's like
totally fucked and
I don't know if it's because we've been
stressing out the levels or not I see the
populace is working fine now
I mean that the obvious is working find out
the whatever happened in the middle of all
that the populist sound driver fucked up and
it makes the signals and it took a reboot to
reset it I could have done it also makes her
fucker out that found the right ones and
reset it but I just reboot
and so it went back and put the mic on the
mic Channel and it puts it put the music on
the movie channel if there's any sound we're
just at all please tell me right away
and
but I'm I'm very serious about this with
everybody I want to I want to actually get
your ID or opinions on here so
I am getting ready to do a lot more IRL
streaming I have a car now my wife just got
a beautiful Baja
a Mike's bring it loud yeah
thank you so so here's what I'm saying
weird going to be on the road a lot more
starting this weekend if not tomorrow and
so anyway I wanted to I'm going to put that
up there and talked to anybody about that
I'm actually seriously thinking about
redoing my entire streaming rig so that and
I thought that this before but I I want to
talk about it
I need a different had those had some but
you had too hot too hot right now
in what might as well get into beer while
I'm at it
hello hello hello hello hello hello hello
and we need some better light in here this
image is very good but oh well
so here's a here's a here's what I'm
thinking
and there's no there's no agenda here I'm
just listening to music and planning the
future and
stream which minute got a lot done
I got to say though I really really really
hope
I really really hope that
that's the cable and now my computer I can
we just all make a make a little prayer
oh fuck yeah my Silo cup my insulated Silo
cup
so so let me take a drink a beer and figure
this out
Here's my thought
this actually this is actually insulated
Silo it like looks like the college beer
pong the cup but not really I didn't have
beer in college cuz I was more money but you
know
goddess of music is great it's hard for me
to think Echo & the Bunnymen people Echo &
the Bunnymen
no one's going to hear that this is not
being streamed to the bod Kisame worries on
my behalf
I'm being on contemplative in beard stroke
you because I
this little this little 22 events have
happened today and I'm just going to reflect
in this is kind of a of log if you want to
call it that it's kind of just a reflection
I got to say there's there's two just two
big things that happened today
three actually that have really motivated me
to think about a pretty significant change
over the next week if not month
the first one is my wife has a car so she
got a Subaru Baja if you guys haven't seen
him go see him and see what a Subaru Baja
looks like it really cute
it's only like three thousand may be made in
the world's there classic there collector's
item
it where you at the end that caused the
problem we're going to get to that we're
going to get to that we are going to get to
that
so I can hear it's like sugar
sugar kisses Ali on streaming
mr. Lee on his stream he's doing a CSS Etc
that's fantastic
pom pom pom
delete ask emotes I do not know what I need
to do I need to actually do
emotes for the strings anyway let's keep
people here so I'm just going to shoot the
shit with a few people who are here
so what do I have to say attorneys to go to
Baja looks like
Subaru Baja they are a collector's item
yes check this out more mobile yeah
yeah well I'm already did that said if you
go back to my boss far enough you'll see I
covered I took my Mac and I took my studio
mic which is behind me back here and I
recorded live music gigs and I've done I
mean it's fine I was laughing doctor
Professor I've done Sound Engineering
professionally I've actually been paid to
run gigs I had a few know. And I can Channel
board and everything and I'm not a pro I
just just a done it if you don't have to be
dangerous so
NSX I think why Sound by being the single
most magical thing you'll ever have in your
gig kit is to add
a cloudlifter and if you don't know what a
cloudlifter is look into it
Roku stick engineer nice
I called the fair is you know the way to go
if you want to get really good performance
at your genetic Mike's including the the
GoWireless to which I use for yoga and stuff
anyway so and there's just there's just no
better is too loud for me
the really the really just know better
system to stream from the Mac iMac his hands
down without a doubt the best system to
stream from it. It's got the best Acoustics
and he just got the best sound setting to me
that's why did you just do it it's got the
best support for twitch everything else you
letting it doesn't have is it it can't play
in obviously can't play in Windows games
but that's that's not why I would use it so
set up the first anything I have to say is
my wife got a car
she got a car to go to Baja and
yeah yeah a Max and Mac is hands-down like
this every single DJ swears by a Mack they
if you see if you see DJs on in a live DJs
every single one every dealer always got
that Natick glowing Apple logo they use max
that that Mac is hands-down locked up the
the the cuz it mean they need rock-solid
equipment when you go in to do Saturday
during a live jagran DJ thing you don't you
know I mean you don't want to have
anything happened you don't want a blue
screen hurting like that and Andi Mack is
Scott the best interfaces uses uses the most
stable at has hands down the best support
for her sound effect of a Pro's Pro Tools
that is only supported on Mac it's it's this
just in the right tool for the job if you're
doing Saturday in your ring or you're DJing
or something like that Max are the tool to
get it you know Apple aside my feelings
about her decide it doesn't matter right so
so so yeah the second thing if you have to
remember I have a laptop I have a Nook and I
Pro
every other phone I have not it sounds like
that so that you're doing it such a fun age
and you have to tell us how it goes
so my wife Monica de Baja Jackson got the
charcoal one try this one exactly right here
set the Baja and that makes us that we have
ancient that apples have of yes
Cycle Products DJ's you smack some people
make DJ software for Mac it really is it is
it is there any compared to some of the
other stuff is out there I mean there are
some YouTube videos of some pretty
substantial media People Media professionals
is switched it to Windows
but
and I I fucking hate Windows I'm just going
to say I hate it I hate 11 I actually I gave
it to all here if you want to try it if you
want to see what does a lot of Mike and did
they actually just a test of this today so
I'm still in point number one which is okay
so that's what I'm going over to whatever
one my wife at a car which means I don't
have my own car to the first time
the first time in our married life I have my
own car she has her car she's got the shells
of the Platypus because it's it's not I have
an apple I have a safe flight back at my my
dream car by the way this is it's literally
the same color and everything is the car I
always wanted and we actually found it kind
of an accident and I had it forever and it's
getting is coming back and and I now I
finally have my own personal car for some of
my life and kitchen floor and before that
was the most remote and working remotely
didn't need an extra car so I prided myself
on riding my skateboard my biking now so can
I still do I still do I like but I've ever
ever had my married life that I've ever had
my own car and it just going to sit there
and if I don't use it so I'm going to
fucking use it
so so I'm just saying a point one here point
one is I car and I'm going to be moving
around a lot and so I'm going to go to
twitchcon
I am going on the calendar of the same way
to go visit on my friends and my family my
my my boys are now through their covalent
want to go visit them yeah I wouldn't be
able to have to have to save up some money
before I do a lot of road trips we just
spent we just paid cash for a car so married
life with a 7-0 got 24 oz Mormon understand
I couldn't have sex unless I got married cuz
I was Mormon so I got more in like 23 24
when people wait but Mormons don't want to
get married in really early cuz he can't sex
now you're going to was Mormon or Armory
well that explains so much about you now
and we pray for your president
so not my favorite song from the skip this
one
music to let me know please I can't hear the
music because the sound is Jeremy really
fucking hate that I can't hear my volume
levels
I I can hear my belt volume levels but I
cannot I can hear the music but you guys get
a different mix and I do and I hate that
because I can't tell the volume levels as
it's like a really annoying thing and that's
a no es required however Fort we should not
get the death of audio it's a fucking sucks
I hate it
you're a deacon how young are you digging
the first thing you know
people Dickinson or 12 so I'm wondering if
you were, that maybe they had it made you
take me to Subway
virtualbox
oh I see there you go it's covered science
in your penis at 11 like every other boy
I just it's a joke it's a joke don't freak
out one in the same Eureka Weird Science
penis we can laugh can we not laugh we can
laugh about that can we not please let me
say it's okay alright so here's like
absolutely City windows
this is
okay I put all people are all adults here we
all went through it
you know what I mean so so I don't have to
say about this
aliens going into detail about the Box model
for HTML websites
again
I was afraid to start this I don't need to
show me when I'm not a fan light number one
and a Hindu it seems to be done today that's
why there's multiple points so the first
point. You know me I don't finish my point
is that my first one is this I have a car
it's not about how I actually have a Subaru
Outback
right I have the green one I have this exact
car right here this one here I want I want
those Wheels oh my God I have to get those
Wheels
woohoo that's exactly as MacArthur so I can
sleep in it I can
I can do a real streaming it it's got a it's
got a sunroof so I can open up and sleep at
night and not suffocate I mean it's just
perfect perfect road trip absolutely
perfect. That's why there's a popular out in
the outback
because you can go anywhere with it
extreme his car did Terry sue his car I did
not know that sounds like I'm moving down
that path very very well maybe I'll be
streaming from the road
at its it's a people colored hipster I don't
give a shit it's practical it has the best
four-wheel drive and gas mileage for a 4
cylinder is a turbo it has the best it's you
don't have to like break your back trying to
get on the table to put a bike on the top of
racking up some like that and so unrelated
to that that means I'm going to be moving
definitely going to
kubecon which I heard is in Detroit
Detroit kubecon
yep
Detroit Michigan October 24th event North
America 2022 so this is not till next
October it gives me a long time to think
about it
yeah can't have shit in Detroit
yeah I know we'll see
I'm in a I'm going to meet County fallen and
all the other people anybody else he wants
to go to kick on and send me my first
conference actually actually no that's not
true it'll be my first bike at all because I
went to SD and Samantha there are no
bathrooms there
I'm at that's fine I'll be fine I'm I
actually stay in a hotel oh my God right I
mean I can I'm usually out of my car I mean
I I I was a river guide my hitchhiking with
hundreds of miles like I know how to do this
stuff on the road fancy
because of the Troy turkey can't have a
shitload
it's like 2 hours for like 2 hours for
everybody 5 hours from people on the west
but it's not even on the East Coast will be
able to make it and I'm I'm on these go so I
kind of want to go meet people
so tell me five hey I'm just tell I'm kind
of doing some planning for the year
it's kind of openly here so my wife got her
car today she got a Baja and that leaves me
with the Outback and
as I told her I know but have to plan it out
that far and it is I got to you know I got
to prepare to save money and shit
this is his we just dropped quite a bit of
money for cash but this car we just bought
anyway we're going to go here
and I don't know how I don't think I'll
present but I I'll definitely have fun and
I'll meet Tony 5 no one else maybe you know
maybe
I do maybe other people be there we'll see
but I feel like this is what I want to go to
I want to get it as soon as I was going on I
want to talk to some of the vendors I might
actually be able to meet some of the vendors
that I actually work with the last search
people that we talk all the time every week
or every other week or so I'm planning on
going to this conference I don't know how
much it cost me to get sponsored by text or
whatever I think they have an office or they
might even help me pay for it and that that
so I have a car I'm going to go to the
conference I'm going to try to go to
twitchcon
twitchcon obsessed with it
this is that's not one streamer dude
I'm not going for partner or anything I
doubt I'll ever make partner because I don't
have the shop study partner I don't have
much wants but whenever I thought God I've
seen some people or partners and I'm like
this person is even stream and their partner
I like what how does it go down
is he staying here for anybody to pay out of
pocket with no corporate for yeah I was
afraid of that I was afraid of that
Natalie Vaughn.
how do I find out who's all the time 25
presents at I mean
so I ain't touch with I don't I kind of like
mixed feelings about this
I probably need a scholarship 95 you know
anywhere I can apply to get a scholarship to
get to talk it's for my scholarship would be
I would be bringing it to the masses I'd be
doing the like live or rent before I'm
through there twitching kind of advocacy for
kubernetes excetera excetera including like
making crazy I hope that somebody will will
pick me up as a sponsor sponsor my
attendance I I don't know I'm I'm yeah we'll
talk about it at some point I I want to go I
want to go yeah if there's somebody that we
can introduce us to make more contact in
person with people who matter in the world
but be on time for there's lots of people
out there are so many of whom have been here
but I would like to supplement that with
some in person comes up
and no potentially I would like to present
to an end
I feel like there's a lot of work that can
be done in the entry-level beginner and
learning space and I I feel like you know is
a professional goal in mind I would like to
Target that area to prepare people for a
structure engineering, native and all that
so that I mean unless it's kind of my goal
this is also the first day because we're
switching over to Virtual machines instead
of using containers which I'll talk about
later and
while I was kind of thinking about the
future I was like no I really like focusing
on infrastructure and and and communities is
dead center in the middle of infrastructure
so that this is a part of who I am I can
leave the the web development to lie on who
I'm actually watching right now if you're
not if you want to do web development go
watch Leon you know Leon's kicking ass with
the you know what this kind of thing I know
is everybody added the CC text button after
I did the video on CC
so I thought that was kind of exciting I
kind of want to get it now
cuz it's a b the font is so much better on
it to do it that way anyway
so makeup Elsa make sure to update early
system today oh I know it ain't about the
doctor thing right yeah the doctor bed bug
yeah if I was to get bug
yeah yeah
Dell yeah yeah
but yeah
if it is darker but doctor I see right yeah
so I mean that would be one of the things
that we could go we could go through
and figure out if someone attend I know I
got wheels I got his she let me recap for
this is joining I got wheels cuz my wife got
her Wheels now I get this car is mine I can
do what I want which means you going to see
me you're going to do we're going to go
running every day again I'm going to go
driving to beautiful places at the sunset
I'm going to go running and I'm going to get
healthy again and probably maybe go paddle
boarding again yeah
how to get is there and get Linux news from
what kind of get it all over Google knows I
want to see everything about Linux these
days but so it shows it in my phone but I
used to have a 7 alert for Linux that I
haven't seen I fall a number of people on
Twitter to actually make a list for that
kind of stuff we do need to cover that in
the booster like who to follow they keep up
on Linux you keep prescient and current step
want to have a car except to I'm going to
keep going and I'm going to try to find
money for that set 3 a.m. so if I have to
use the stream funds by the way thank you
again I got another $8 get up Spencer today
appreciate that I really do I really
appreciate that every dime that you help me
out with helps me produce Community content
including you know live coverage of kubecon
for our community from the beginner
perspective that's all stuff that I that I
just want to keep continue to I really love
it and
andand
and it's gone I do want to go to twitchcon I
don't know if I am Twitchy enough to go to
twitchcon
I don't know how much money is going to cost
to go to twitchcon I mean I would almost
rather go to to to Defcon
but Defcon is really spending here's the
info on scholarships oh thank you
thank you thank you thank you I got money
now but I got money now but but it's still
be nice it was to help meet the needs I am
supporting my wife as well so
and I got to go meet with I want to be able
to pay to go see my kids I haven't seen my
kids in 7 years and I don't have a car I can
attend Cove it's dying down and they've all
had covid-19 afraid of it without me being
there that one of my kids they lock him in a
room in a covid dorm I got to call him and
check in on it see if he's okay because you
know it's like it seriously and my kids here
I could be I have not had it yet no
made my python users
that's not just a courtesy yeah but I was
too but
130 people have had covid have had it yet I
don't know what I mean I don't know what
would be more fun if there's a part of me
that really wants to go to switch but I if I
go to Twitch I want to meet specific people
from twitch is a few other twitch streamers
that I might want to meet with and see how
they did it you know the IRL streamer is a
Church's overrun by mostly game streamers
but there are some Adderall streamers that I
that I look up to you and I I like what
they're doing so that might be a reason to
go to put it on for the most part that I
think that going to come would be way more
valuable so if I have to pick one that will
be it
we'll see I don't know it looks like they're
in Amsterdam and San Diego Ice to
conferences in October
and that would be a no that's a no for
twitchcon I think I can't go this site going
to be right at the same time
as you can so can't do that what's that
the hell song is this
monetarily beneficial I don't lie you can
see people would watch it I don't I don't
know that that's true actually especially
since I'm planning on publishing a book or
two here within the next year
about Community stuff
2 Chainz money in reach you
I know I don't know I don't know we'll see
we'll see
I mean I would rather stick to Amazon they
definitely do
an article on people you know we've been
talking about that for a long time and I
and that's a massive undertaking if I did
that it would break up the calendar as a
problem that's the training counter we have
that if we reach out and we actually get
more people involved we might be able to
pull something like that off
you know I don't know I don't know I mean
if I did anything like that would be kind of
like a non-conference we would just all you
know rent a rent a place to stay and we just
go there and hang out but why can't we just
do that here you know
French artifacts Gallery Mexican conditions
yeah
yep yep yep yep if anybody so okay so the
three things happened the first thing was
she got the car so I'm free I have a car my
own now secondly is I got my Mac Pro for
work work Splurge free to have a problem
with 16 MB RAM and I think my work computer
is more powerful than 10 Mi streaming system
it's the laptop and I'm going to swing from
that obviously it's a work work work
resource
work resource but because it's a work
resource and it's a laptop and I also
already have another Mac Pro MacBook Pro I'm
seriously considering changing my primary
streaming system to the MacBook and let me
see why if I stream from the Mac I can pick
it up and take it with me wherever I go and
I don't have to reset the streaming settings
I don't have to reset the clicker but sorry
they're right I plug in a remote video I
have another one I am SSH into systems where
I'm doing stuff I have enough course to be
able to run even virtualbox and all that in
it and that's what I want to test I'm going
to make it right for the back obviously
we'll be using Linux on the Mac I won't be
using the you know that BSD stuff I'll just
use Linux on there
and many other dangers of that is it when
I'm not working when I'm not working all I
have to do is plug one thing into my
computer laptop and now now my work laptop
all of a sudden takes advantage of my
monitor setup and everything and yes I have
a KVM I can do in a split monitors across
two different things I have that working it
works fine is really great I love it but the
point I'm trying to make here is that
I have the ability to Interchange
the computer really quickly and Ed to take
with me on the road so why is it why does
that matter because let's say one night I
want to go to the pub I literally just
unplug my Mac Pro grab my my my studio mic
and we go to the pub and we do a stream from
the pub maybe one weekend I want to go I
want to go camping so I grabbed again I grab
them I go I do the hotspot for that night
plug it in a plug my phone into the car
battery so we don't be dead or get one of
these portable car batteries like Daniel has
Leslie has used to Leslie's car battery is
super cool as a portable battery that you
can just carry around with her just looked
in your these really cool so I just take we
just go and then we go wherever we have no
reception I just go there and and I like a
rib-eye oh system and you know so those
moments where I black out and stuff like
that I can so that I can do a full-blown IRL
streaming which I've been wanting to do all
along so
so that just the so they said if I were
going to go right now and have to grab my
phone is true for my phone and I don't mind
sharing app for my phone I like it is fun at
all but it would be so much better if I
could if I was streaming from the Mac
because then I could actually work from the
mac & Stream at the same time even if I'm in
the car so if I'm in the front seat in the
back of the car in the mall I'm all cozy
doubts you know we could we could do that
in fact speaking to Cosi let's do this
aspect look for some cozy shall we let's
look for some cozy
I'm looking for that the Cozy background
there's like a really really cozy one with
the van
here we go oh my God it's too loud
I thought that too loud
so if I got a crown how's that
I asked me to move my guy is somewhere else
a table streaming to a projector and or live
web what's up look like
USB capture card and a signal of time I have
that already
yeah I already have a card are you talking
about and see if I did if I did set up an
event and it can't be in your name it would
be we depend on knowing you have why does
this song sound like there's two sippy yeah
there's a bunch of cool ones
so I don't know I why is it not changing
I hate this does aJesus and Mary Chain
at your streamer in your Workstation
yeah we could do that I mean I can stream to
do the Tremont workstation but I don't mind
in my case I would need to stream from it
that the problem was my fear lately be
copper so local
I mean here here's the think so lately
lately well Professor I know you mean well
but having a separate computer for streaming
and having a capture card is problematic
because of the transitions
so unless you add an extra device for the
transitions I don't know of a way to make it
easy to transition between different scenes
and stuff so you have to have no one you
know computer wreck right in front of you
and then the other one they are actually
working from one of the things I like about
this is because I can I can switch between I
can switch between reviews pretty easily
just going to keep her right now because cuz
I'm streaming from the same system at work
and I mean it's risky and I have multiple
monitors so that I can make sure that the
thing that streaming isn't something you
know bad but so that's that's why I'm kind
of against however however the capture card
does come into play when I do things like
gaming right so
I mean it's pretty common for people to
recommend to recommend
it's recommend streaming when you're from a
Windows machine so here's here's one
possible future okay
one possible future is that I put graphene
OS
I'm going to change between my parents find
out
what one possible future would be I only
stream from my Mac I think I had to do
things safely from the Mack
if I buy Slater computers at her desk yeah I
mean it's another way to do it I didn't want
to do virtual machine so that more than that
I think the pipe or can handle screw me but
I wouldn't I wouldn't do that
and it's so so the way this goes down so I'm
considering
are you Siri turning my my 16 core gaming PC
into a server right so it would just be
I want to do things this is kind of this is
kind of a dilemma for me I can either make
it just a server or I can make it only a
Windows gaming system
because she can't really do both right
that's it that stuff right to strictly
speaking eventually I want to get a thread
repair I have to save my money for that
eventually I will get a thread repair I feel
like it's not going to be a gaming system is
because the day the truth I want to I want
to downplay any time over Play 3 hours of
Dota 2 hours a day I want to downplay that I
want to turn that time into productive time
outside on the road instead of like playing
games and I love games God knows I do but
it's so my current plans are I think I
pretty much solidified that to turn my
gaming rig which is what it is it's an MSI
gaming rig in case you guys haven't seen the
settings on it for you
I even have a terminal can you believe that
what is the world coming to miss Rob doesn't
run a terminal
Atlas proxmox as you pass away yeah yeah I
thought about doing that Massey and I'm
actually seeking to understand how to do
that I don't have any idea I don't know
right now I have no idea how to do what you
just said but I think we could definitely at
some point so
pop away neofetch
so I do have a gaming rig this is a pro
gaming room it is that's what it is it's
really really nice computer I thought about
selling it and getting it Fredrik Randstad
which I might still do I mean we got so much
money coming in
I figure maybe I'll just keep this as my
gaming rig and then I'll have the streaming
Mac and then I'll and then I'll have you
know that's right here at 4 with three cords
at some point for my main server and then
that would be the extent of it. That is if I
go on the road if I have a server at home I
don't have to use I know if I can actually
do my own OBS in a port forwarding and do my
own for my GoPro and stuff like that and I
have all that still sell
they crash when I miss them what's that
Verizon towers
interesting yeah
I really need to look at proxmox a lot I've
been really seriously cuz that might
actually go look at it right now
cuz I heard a lot of good things about it
virtual machines that have access to pee you
yeah give me a password that that's what I
was going to say there I I know that that's
not true because I've used my cheap you from
a virtual machine in 2013 I had pneumonia
and I need you to your password by Dota 2
and a bunch of awesome games that he's gay
maker from a Linux machine used to be at
work I didn't do anything worked so
because I never like to see what this Red
River I don't know we'll see
but we definitely need to look at I need to
look at a server and that guy Professor if
you have strong opinions on that I'd love to
hear him I was actually asking hit tennis
the other day about his opinions on the best
server to get best server tower for
virtualization probably in the consumer real
not in the kind of the Enterprise rental on
top of Dave and I have kitty
I think that you don't need for Xbox that
remote has pretty much the same seriously
nice yeah I really want to try that I really
want to try that
yeah so so so yeah I'm just I'm kind of you
know if you're just running the street and
I'm just here spitballing so future stuff to
do
the new hops have to go look for that
again I don't I don't want really okay so
that's probably not going to happen for year
right cuz I got to be dumping all kinds of
money on IRL streaming stuff the way I have
already have printed spent money on that
I actually lost my $100 40 router I can't
find anywhere I'm so pissed
if I D rather actually it's the latest one I
got the latest and greatest and then just
fucking lost it I think it fell out of my
coat while I was running
I'm so mad I I can't think about I get to
upset I can't focus
yeah so is that got stolen
but but you know I found that you don't
actually need
if a 40 router if you can use hotspot just
fine as long as you have power you have to
have power and we have power and signal so I
don't need to get fancy like that I'm not
going to I'm not going to make a gun runner
back I'm not going to do that on this too
much money is too much money is not worth it
and the rates are too high so I'm making my
own thing out of Raspberry Pi at some point
I think we talked about doing it but I don't
I don't I don't want to I just want to get
outside and if that means stream from my
phone on my back when I have Wi-Fi fine
love America maze yeah you guys probably
could know about that more than me
so
so yes I got a car when you get outside I'm
going to go start IRL streaming now
regularly like every weekend Friday or late
I'm going to be running a lot more outside
and be a lot more outdoor streaming I got
some really I got a really great Mike
equipment for doing like ASMR outdoor
outdoor sound videos with like in a stream
music like water and rivers of stuff I'm
looking really really forward to the way
it's going right now I have all the
equipment to do really intense as some more
outdoor really sensitive Mike stuff so when
we can just go in a walk through the woods
kind of thing I want to do that instead of
game can take over my gaming time I still
have something to do Saturday and Sunday
streams but you get a chance that the
Saturday and
chance that the Saturday and Sunday streams
that we do I might even do it from the road
so there's no reason not to you know
and yeah jaunting I we were calling it
jontay and yes
and that's where we are
and talk about the Mac thing about him going
to possibly switch over
and the third thing is is this is bulshit
that happened with the sound and Papa was
today so I am done with Papalis the only
thing keeping me on pop OS right now is it's
drop dead simple ability to game with steam
and I don't know that I can't do that from
Linux Mint
but if I if I start streaming for my Mac and
we start focusing on Virtual machines for
our Linux stuff which is really all I ever
give a shit about I do not care about that
the only thing
I care about is being able to do this
does anybody know if MPV exist
for mac and I'm sure if not there's
something that it does have it
yeah chocolate games could be baby
what the fuk was that that's like I have I
have
I have a ton of videos
that you can pull up anytime
I mean yeah so this
what I was trying to say is
that is the only this up in a graduation
that I have
then I would be sad to lose and that's
because it uses MPV and I don't think you
can use MPV on Mac
MP MP3 on Mac and BB
nope
if she made a laptop in a crash who gives a
shit how's it going on
I saw saw Perrin extra memory are the BC I
like wait an hour and it was a picture of
this
yeah you have to figure out how to do oh
wait we way that's different
we talking about if we could stream in front
of people I don't care if the stream dies in
front of people
I don't care if they do that that I just
know if I don't want it to go away
yeah I don't I don't know I don't know but
that I mean persistent USB sticks or not
persistent right so anything you put on
there's going to go away but if you're
saying that it's like the whole thing out
wiped I don't know that's me different thing
and it is part of a of a homburg or
seriously oh man that's good news
because that's like they got it mercifully
shit
wow that's like really that's a big deal
that I can use my tools I can just I can run
him wrong Mac right and everybody knows Max
got the best out-of-the-box terminal has
down there it's just it's still comparison
short of Lennox obviously but when it's just
it's fantastic that's why it's so popular
and this is not an employee as far as I know
thank God for the one I have is anyway
I can I want to swap out the keyword I hope
they give me a new one are you taking a
going to change if I did
I know I don't I did not come from the sea
shall I put it back on there and immediately
it takes two seconds to put back on there as
soon as
as the default I've been doing that for
years and it's like you just is going to
Idaho all Maxima school right and you go on
there and you just do the stalking to your
tails and takes over bash. Boom and
everything for that every login to give a
show from the Sun
turn on turn off the terminals internals
kickass it is like I turn too and I'm so
going to put it on there now and then
you say that this point it doesn't even
start Lennox in the computer doesn't
recognize us
it doesn't recognize its own OS you might
have it you might have some swordfish
software
if your booty from USB and you're getting
parent of some random site I would be scared
if you might get hot you might be hacked
back to the shop take any harm repair
oh God so
is there dollars so I know what to say here
I come back to normal mode
do I need to really think through this
because if I do is wrong then my stream will
die and you know I'll just ring for my phone
if I have two God damn it. I'll just plug my
phone in the stream from right here I don't
care anymore because the green screen give a
shit
yeah so what are your concern is it's like
I'm sorry I don't have a better answer for a
debit on I don't
I don't have it why you see. Anyway and once
you make your own
build your own arch and put your own tools
on there every day for hiking it's a great
that's a great tool that you know
I tried. I tried. And I was like well you
know I could just do my thing you know I
could pick them out and then you can I can
pick your own tools to make your own USB
stick
have you better to do that way LXI MacBook
because the device drivers and support
everything we tried it already
yeah actually I don't have to try the latest
ones
but
we we did we did Linux
on a MacBook have a friend a good friend who
who is swears by lettuce on a MacBook and I
can't remember the one that was right after
the year of mine and he tried to do it and
he had to bring
I think he lost USB support
so that was it
yeah he lost his music so he couldn't hear
the bottom line is that Max does not support
Linux running on the hardware I know for a
fact that the Mac Minis that I have work
absolutely fine with their phenomenal but
but they walked around the hardware beyond
the end one thing to try to get him so they
don't run Linux well
but you can actually run Linux pretty well
and unless mix
so so yeah the main reason I went was
because I wanted to smack for the reason I'm
using I guess not because I just want to get
Hardware it's because I want the Mac
interface and I want the stability of Mac
exedra
and my papa list of if there's one thing
Papa's can bring it convinced me again
lately is it you're going to hate hearing me
say this but desktop Mac desktop Linux is
still not there it's still not there it's
not rock solid and I put desktop I put dust
up Linux to put Benadryl on all the
computers in my lap and it break every one
of them
and you know populace was like the easiest
of all men has never done this to me meant
has never done this to me I've done this to
myself with mint and but but an endless look
I love love love love Linux I love it I love
the people using on the desktop I love Jamie
from right now I live and I can stream from
it I like all the progress is making it at
the end of the day I'm sorry desktop Linux
does not hold a candle to Mac it just
doesn't and and that's that's that's sad to
say I was in the MacBook Air and the only
problem is with Wi-Fi driver yeah that was
sent from we had we had to prom with Wi-Fi
driver but you know it's not a small problem
when your Wi-Fi doesn't work
and it's mostly because of broadcom and
brought accounts for Friday at Terry
excetera excetera do I like saying these
words no I fucking hate it but I'm just
telling you the state of reality this is
where we are you know there's heaps of who's
going to do that a bunch of can't but most
of those things only matter if you're
managing a very large leave a yes and that's
why you say that because it had with tennis
was taking a shit because he was using a Mac
I'm sorry he was using a Windows machine to
manage his home cluster because he was using
it was only available on Windows and I know
I don't like that if I think I think you I
think that's fair to say I already here is
actually agreeing with what's his ass Linus
Tech tips on this the same thing that he and
I fought about I'm completely agree with him
on this
I don't think I think they made great
strides into the gaming world and I think
that's fantastic and I think Lenox is
awesome and I believe in the Linux
open-source philosophy etc etc but
you know at the end of the day it's just not
there yet
yeah it was nice that your home system right
it is our hope that you should care about
how how people to protect you just want to
be productive as long as they're not
violating security policy or do it like that
so if you want to go to yeah it's a good one
and I'm going to I'm going to confess
something here
yeah and I mean yeah but it's very person I
think that they should I did I did when I
was in my twenties 20's and 30's right by
fishermen so so what I'm not advocating for
people to drop Lennox on their home desktops
I think you should definitely do it but I
think what there are times when you have to
make a really you have to make a decision
based on more criteria that then then Lennox
will support for sampled same reason for Mac
nobody would know it don't want to be with
rational a pic a Mac for gaming today I mean
come on that's like stupid is just as good a
right to be a G+ message via at Massey see
I'm kind of with you on that this is what I
actually said was you said it because hit
head town is his kind of convince me of
something that I was already trying
to do in my mind I was having a hard time
rationalizing it you don't came I'm going to
say something it's going to be very
controversial I use Lenox for servers and
containers
it was my window manager and I don't give a
shit what you want a manager
I don't have a window manager I'm America
with his you're not a real Linux person okay
fine I buy
goodbye I need to go make more money
supporting and maintaining thousands of
Linux systems while you go off your little
way seriously it if you going to look down
on somebody because their home system hey
greetings is not Lenox then you really
really don't get Linux at all because the
recent Linux is a worldwide phenomenon it's
not because of ifucking free it's not
because of desktop Linux at all
is because of Linux as a server Linux as an
underlying operating system
anything we could keeping
is an issue I guess Windows runs on MacBooks
very well yes haven't tried that I am
actually I did know Ida parallels I did I
did a headache the trash can and we still
have it because I'm by the trashcan Mac Pro
we haven't rushed and it's got its got a
weird external drive for Windows and run
parallels on there
what is VMware is it called a paralyzed or
whatever it is VMware VMware has has a thing
in the lie to run Windows on Mac and it
worked very well I was running Windows on my
back for a long time
yeah and we had to because SolidWorks so
SolidWorks is hands-down the leading tool
for you know 3D design and stuff for you
know the 3D printing and I kind of think
it's Windows only software you can't you
can't use it for anything munis
is it suck unless games yeah if using games
whatever whatever works for you against the
job
view against the job. But it's a place that
makes fun of my IQ is but a short for the
battery assist issue situations Mac hardware
last for fucking ever it's kind of a
downside to the company because they make
something it just stays around forever Mac
hardware is fantastic add and that's all I
have to say about that I mean Rob no one's
going to attack Rob Pike who invented go and
unicode before you see if you'd be a fool
yeah there's a certain point at which it's
like a tool and if it gets this job done who
gives a shit when does the store games have
a proprietary apps that you have three other
than that there's more suffering will be for
like some just absolutely
depends on the software though so right so
this isn't an either-or proposition in fact
in this case it's all I'm actually going to
have one of each which I am going to say if
you have the money if you have the money and
you want to be a well-rounded technologist
you should learn all of it you should learn
Mac you should learn how to administer a Mac
system desktop system you should learn how
to do your windows gaming you know and all
of its glory and stream and all that shit
and use capture cards all that shit you know
and you should learn you should learn Linux
you should be learning some the server
should learn on the desktop you should learn
Raspberry Pi
if you want to be a true well-rounded
technologist you should learn all of it you
stop stop hobbling yourself by saying oh I'm
only a Linux person right so
and I agree which one I mean it really
depends
yeah I went back to CR and it'll do it
perfectly oh yeah
and I prefer your personal system 06
environment tomorrow I would be screwed it's
hard to that's hard to say that but I don't
know how do you so fucking travel about all
this and I'm just as guilty as anybody right
I mean we really do it it's like we have to
stop being tribal about keyboards and and
and in an operating systems it so I got to
pick the best tool for the job and and have
the courage to say when the tool that
someone including you is using is not the
right tool right
restart system 76
yeah it was actually a lot of money we
talked about that we talked about that the
other day yeah it is
OS X is the largest official Unix
Distribution on the planet
and that's coming from the Unix they paid a
lot of money for the apparently it was
telling me about that so maybe some of it
will you tell me a song about that came over
who sang it
yeah they were like saying it was like a big
deal
other platforms right it's literally the
largest unit To Us by the planets yeah I
think it was and it's it's actually that's
like a factual they're like yeah I mean they
did they'd still be yes. Yes did they not
really get that much back yes was Steve Jobs
a you know a shilling a stealer and a thief
yes by his own admission flip multiple times
you can criticize the company on multiple
points and God knows I do but at the end of
the day you know it's still the best unique
system out there for the most people
Microsoft at the Lennox enjoy yourself I'm
silly and dumb at this after so far I hate
it I hate it I I said that after with lot of
experience
I was a big proponent of wsl2 until I
couldn't use it to get any work done because
they it doesn't work with Cisco anyconnect
for VPN
add the first time that I fucked over a
directory because it tried to mail something
it's a brilliant thing it's a move in the
right direction I still fucking hate it I
hate it I hate it I hate the did you know
this look you cannot run Windows actually
test this today I test I read about it I
didn't believe it holyshit mr. learn with
Leon's here while we're drinking beer
Leon and I got you on here on the other
window I should have saw it coming oh my God
you snuck in
I was I was like I was I had you on the
other window I was sitting here watching you
I was talking about you to everybody while
you came in and oh my God I guess I guess
I'll have to turn the phone on applications
off for a while I'm at that has turn the
alerts off
that's what I will thank you we're having a
hard time reading anything here
I was going to let this go through for a
while it's kind of fun to happen hey
somebody clip this is like the clip from Lee
on the clip of death from Leon Leon I was
actually have new problems now because I'm
usually able to read everything everybody
say so I should probably turn on slow chat
or something like that but I have no idea
we're listening to we're listening to some
music by the way lest anybody get afraid of
what's happening today
this music is not being stream to Twitch
it's going to channel to and in your OBS
which stops it from getting saved in a
twitch fraud and twitch actually committed
and made this dispatch to OBS So for anybody
who out there who is interested in and
sometimes maybe streaming stuff that you
know is on the copyright gray area like oh I
don't know Morrissey or or something like
that you can still do it and you can do that
I should probably tell everybody what I do
here since we have so many visitors we were
honestly we were just shooting the shit and
and and having some fun and this is a rated
M stream I say fuck a lot so if you don't
like that you probably don't want to be here
I don't mean any offense to anybody who's
offended by that but I just want to let you
know
add a task to thank thank you for the right
appreciate it everybody I let me give you
the calendar right now since I can't really
read anything anybody saying
and we'll go back to some other some other
stuff Etsy
you guys no pulp I don't know nobody no
hears those Folk
you guys know where it's at Versailles from
me do you know cars let me see if you can
find something that you like
my God I haven't I've never had to deal with
this before it's calendar wise
so is this the calendar so coming up coming
up on May 4th I'm going to start going to be
loose I really like that LeAndre to be
because it's it cuz I think that went Leon
is doing is is complimentary at but
different and I'm I'm happy for four people
like likely on because they have they made
it so that I don't have to focus on only
remove the following application so that I
don't have to focus on web development even
though I was with developer how is it
webmaster and thank you for years and I
didn't I don't have to focus on that you
know I'm saying so let me go ahead and turn
that off I can
I'm sorry I meant I'm a small-time streamer
so I'm not used to this big big ass
Community coming on in
that's Professor is he is a sweetheart yes I
am kind of a streamer so anyway I don't know
if you're going to be able to see this
normally you would this is the link to the
lake if you go to RDX
HTTP let me see if I can go there for if you
go to if CPS get hub.com boost you can go
here I mean here in this one everybody we
were likely to see or talk to my wife just
got a new car today and I was talking about
all the IRL streaming on when they start
doing where you go to the kubecon and
they're cheaper Nettie's and and stuff so
this is an old
so we can do that I might go ahead and edit
some of the stuff
but if you want to learn anything on their
command line that's what we do here and I go
into the Boost and I'll show you that the
first day of the boo so we can be doing
so we're discovering virtualbox virtual
machines with him covering Linux but as I
said I've more or less removed a lot of the
web development stuff because Liana people
like me on cover it so well so that leaves
me to cover you know how to get really you
know deep and and you know down and dirty
with the the server-side kinds of things
you're bordering on hacking a couple things
out I'll mention really quick yeah I record
everything so every Saturday every Saturday
we go from about yes all free everything is
free I really love that about Leon you know
my favorite quote from the office I have to
say this okay my favorite Leon quote is this
you can learn how to hack yes you can tell
her how to hack we do it a lot we do over
the wire and stuff like that but you know
what hacking is really just understanding
how a computer works but you understand how
do computer work so you don't have to learn
how to hack you
so then it's just a matter of like thinking
about it and I'm going forward and that kind
of thing you like the 11:11 that's pretty
fun so so what I want to say about that is
that you know I've started school start back
in 2013 I quit my job and I retired it's
fixed 40% of my retirement out to start a
company and I run that company for about 8
years in this company is called skill stack
s k i l s t a k. I owe and this is just a
continuation of that company online and I
decided to go really informal with it but
but I'm doing the same content and the
content is based on and you can look at my
about if give give her a bout if if if you
want to read about my background and why you
should listen to me except for Terry can go
back and look at you and I would do the same
thing I mean I don't I don't like listening
to people blindly but so so every May 4th is
that thing I was just have so many new
people here I'm going to go ahead and talk
about this so we're all going to lose
but we're going to be doing we're going to
start with the terminal all right so we're
going to learn Linux we're going to reverse
a box if you want to get started right away
you could go install virtualbox on your
machine on your Lennox machine or I am sorry
I am a curry Windows machine and then you
can get going with Lennox at y Lennox right
well Lenox is the most powerful operating
system on planet Earth right now and let
people know this but your Mac is actually
the largest Unix distribution in the
universe it's it's it's the first one and
and Lennox I'm not talking about Linux on
the desktop so let me let me just be really
clear here okay let people mistake what I'm
saying is Kelly cool it's a mistake by
Raspberry Pi slowly okay absolutely if
you've got one people mistake when I say
Linux I don't mean a desktop Linux and a lot
of people will immediately think of things
that you don't like this what you will talk
about and a lot of other great streamers
we'll talk about Linux and we'll talk about
it from the
so the guy can we game with it right in fact
we have a little bit of drama I don't mind
that she has drama with Linux does the tech
tips over the over the and the slamming of
Lennox touring the whole game thing with
Luke that we've patched out all up and we're
all friends now my time zone my timezone is
usually printed down here it's switching out
right now we're doing kubernetes stuff but
usually my timezone is down on the screen
it's always only see me on the terminal I
see your dinner tonight May 4th okay and I'm
I've got we got two or three months to
organize this and that this right here is
the countdown timer will be starting a boost
content in 98 days and
you like talk talk it's pretty good to hear
music patch thing yeah I made a video on the
music thing if you want to go to my videos
yeah if you want to go to videos you could
do
I don't know which video I made about it
it's now probably get you the link we see if
I can find it if you want it if you want to
learn how to stream I just feel 80s music on
today but I but I see turn off which which
trading Soca music issues with you too much
which now it's me complaining
I see OBS Twitch streaming setup no that's
not it something you want me to show you
real quick if you want me to show you want
me to show you it's really easy to show you
alright so we just have this is all it is
this is all you do people
so this is all it is this is you guys having
that thing where this is all you do so you
do settings
right and you go to Advanced
and which one is its audio sorry is it audio
is a general where is it
where is the Kern River it's the alignment
sensitivity preview
basically you have to turn it on I think
it's under audio I want to send audio
maybe not a commute why isn't it here hey hi
where is it
I did a whole video I can't remember if this
is all I can tell you how to do your
captions for the record I'm on my third beer
and we were just we were just relaxing today
so that's why I really love having you I'm a
little bit more formal other times but
active Rica I do have active you call I have
I have I'll get it for you here here you go
is that query
audio let's see what that gives this right
zet edit audio
is serious or is that yeah it's funny I
created a whole stencil let me give you that
give her I use it as that method for
managing my notes and I'll show you how to
do it I forgot his script your own if you
want here's all my titles I used this for
everything again him has built-in searching
so you can go go back to that show and it's
when I have a there's a video in here about
twitching a little bit just to bug you again
I'm on my third pure and she kind of caught
me off-guard I think you were being here
though just so fun let's see if this dude is
that what did I do to buy I want to see edit
twitch let's see what's twitch videos we
have API documentation twitch partner and
got denied so far switching mode switch API
I only my other it is so I wrote a whole
thing on it there's my zettelkasten ID so
that's number 15 and here's how to do it and
there's the video that goes with it all
automatically added to my guitar and
synchronize to my description on my video I
can show you how to strip that we've drifted
that is cryptic is magical bash scripting is
so magical because you can make it do things
you would even believe that you can do so
here it is it's like settings output and and
then what then what so let's go to that so
it's settings output no wonder I missed it
okay so it's under output and then when we
got
we have this right here and Abel Advanced go
her settings and right here see this you see
twitch vod's Syracuse track 2
you like it I'm so happy you said so yeah
that's what got you into web dev you like
bash that much I owe we are together we are
soulmates I am Aventuras my favorite
language you know why because it enables so
many things if you want to do something
simple right is that say let's say let's say
you're just I don't know let's say let's try
something here okay since your phone right
we're going to be like what's like make a a
file if you ate food HTML let's just Lance
HTML right let's let's make let's make a web
page and say here's my here's my title right
I would say let's make a bolt for the list I
say I like something here that we can learn
mark down right this is what's so amazing
about bash in the command line you can stay
another thing
and if you don't know what, Mark you might
want to learn it since you're learning each
to know you're right in the right place to
learn common marker markdown because it goes
with it you can say one to you know and then
you could do like 3 and then you can go up
here and you can convert all of this into
HTML and one command watch this through the
magic of Bosch and eunuchs philosophy which
uses filters you can send that to pandoc and
boom you have
Doc and boom you have HTML automatically
you see how that automatically change it to
HTML let's say I just want to change this
that's changed let's say I want to change
just this this just the stuff right here to
the we want to change the white people
always ask me why do you got ones there why
you got ones there what's up with the ones
you know I like because I don't have to give
a shit about what the numbers are because
watch this your comes to magical bash been
filtering through! I go I was that I don't
even remember it the right bracket and down
here it says send the next four lines to the
following program I'm going to send it to a
program called pandoc and boom I just made a
list out of them
let's say let's say I don't want to make it
into HTML what's say I want to make that
into it is a magic bash and it's actually
the magic of the eunuchs filter philosophy
which is everything is a pipe all the input
from one thing can go into the output of
nothing when did you Jason yeah let's do
let's do this let's just make it regular
text right so I have text that just came in
the text if I want to do this when I
converted to text you for distance to text
you know it's converted to PDF here's some
crazy I should watch this weekend like two
math in here tonight at let's say time
seeing 534 right and and then and then so
let's do this at the scale at the scale
which is you know scale equals to now that
doesn't look like much but that's actually
code that's code to a program called BC and
now we can run this through BC which is a
calculator
it's built into Linux and you get the
results 3.06 let's say you want to stick a
calendar in here you want to stick the
calendar in here right you can do bang bang
to! It's too! To type Cal and Bam I have a
calendar in here and now you have and if you
wanted to see the explanation of how to do
this if I used to look through my things so
I can split a pain real quick and I Can Shed
I can give you the the summation of this
Witch is here I called it VI magic and and
that's just That's The Departed people are
most one away by is being able to send your
output to the input of nothing so let's say
I have a thing and I want to I want to make
that into a into a title I have a h title
and it was something in there s a i have I
want to just put a new title that has the
current time stamp I have a script called HD
all of this is Bash all of this is bad it's
not some funking funky functions you know
likely will plug-in if uses bash every
single thing I just did is because of the
eunuchs philosophy which means that you take
something that has an input and you convert
it and then you replace it with its output
you can actually write code to ride code
watch this so you can write code to write
code you can say for i n I don't know one to
3023 whoops I turn off my sound on accident
sorry
I think I my sis my sound off when I do you
guys still there
are you guys still there or am I music oh
god dammit
I think I think I did I think I'm using my
mic I did
there is a fine I just I mean me music is
off Music Died
and that dude die for you two all right
all right okay so then we go to sleep I'm
going to say so this this you like what the
fuck is this is this, Mark what is this this
is Bash I'm running bash in my document why
the fuck what I do that right Echo
are we going to Echo i n n a. Item right and
then done that is a line of Bosch every
semicolon is a line return and you send that
to bash us a bang-bang bash and boom it
creates all those lines for you did I have
to do anything fancy for that did I have to
add a plug-in did I have to create a titty
think know I just learned bash and I use VI
as God intended at your to integrate the
filter command which is the! That called the
magic wand people say that's the bad thing,
I don't care and
and you know and it's you can do whatever
you want it what is your favorite what is
your favorite language maybe you guys like
python maybe like JavaScript you wanted to
JavaScript listener JavaScript console.log
why but I see something here I don't know
what you would do but you can write
JavaScript and then you can send that to
node and that will replace it with its
output so you can write it in Python for
God's sake you can't use any scripting
language you want to and integrate them
because of the eunuchs philosophy which is
do one thing well and have it connect with
other stuff and if you want to see I have a
bunch of commands that do these little tiny
thing so i k h Title Here is a filter script
this is a filter bash script that does some
pretty funky math it it comes in it takes in
the input it is centers it and it allows it
to be its thing that's a little hard when we
could do this one we could do this one this
is
do this one does is run a program see this
is the Unix philosophy here again we have
this one line program right age now prints
out the title right I can do that for him to
sign a document or outside of it and then we
have this other program that we made called
now what what is it what is that what's in
that program there's the program for now and
what is now calling now is calling date okay
well what is that doing you know so that we
can say so now is now I can say it now plus
next Friday
and then we get exactly next Friday at 12
a.m. and we get to we get to mesh together
all of these little commands and that is the
way we make a joke here you know from
Mandalorian this is the way this really is
the way this is the way to absolute power
absolutely power because you are using the
Unix philosophy to tie things together to do
other things and you can do that to generate
web pages you can do it to vet your code you
can do it too into it and it takes time to
learn this year the Jedi Arts of the
terminal and I'm going to say it you don't
need to learn this to get a job you know you
could just learn JavaScript and weather
going to help people get jobs you only know
that but when you do have those actually
teaching a homemaker a mother and she was
trying to learn JavaScript you had no idea
about directory tree structures I tried to
use
the relation of a directory tree to have
them understand you know what it meant to be
you know what what directories were and I
should get it it's under the command line
and I showed her you know what the tree
command or something like it
and you know and and she immediately wanted
me to show her the terminal because she saw
how much power is there so whether you are a
web developer or you are back in developer
or you want to go on to become a hacker or
an infrastructure engineer or anything
related to technology you learning the way
of the eunuchs way and I say the eunuchs way
because this free dates Lennox by decades
people have been doing this and they have
been they've been doing this in behind
closed doors this is largely been traveled
all just been handed down by a gray beards
to other greybeards which is very
misogynistic term I'm sorry but it's largely
been tribal knowledge has been handed down
by a Prentice 22 pod one and it has happened
because it's not taught in school so this is
the kind of thing that's been passed down
for Generations I was very lucky I was you
know I was taught by you know some great
beers at an internet service provider that I
that I worked for before they head down to
beans Nike Roshes Nikes with master
before I did all that and it's one of the
reasons I'm here is because I'm sick and
tired of this being some dark-skinned no
Wizardry out there it needs to be out in the
wild people need to know that I used to be
taught so because I believe personally I
believe personally that it will help anyone
it will help anyone become better even if
you don't need it it will make you better I
actually was one guy who got to hit it and
get it got an internship and actually I'm
kind of done bragging here guys on Friday
I'm going to brag a little bit I'm so proud
of the people that I placed one of the guys
that I place he won the internship he was to
use a psychology graduate and then he he
came because you couldn't get a job to the
psychology grad in it and and he came to me
and said I need help and so over the next
two years he spent
he spent no more than four grand with me and
I had those back in as soon as Mentor me for
money which I'm not doing any more pressure
support and everything but I don't you know
I don't charge and and he have a full-time
job to pay for that by the way that's what I
do not and he he actually won out of 40
people in the internship he won the position
and he got hired and the guy that hired him
sent me this really nice notice security of
the town for educating people take I know
this is bragging I'm sorry but since I got
so many people are figure I might as well
try and he said after your member successor
I suspect the review team will be even more
urgent and pick you up when you're too soon
as we've had a lot of young writer answers
to some of the top universities that country
in your member was right in the mix of them
when he had his interview his interviewer
did not know how to use to bi in the
terminal and was using go from you no BS
code which is fine it's awesome but it was
he shared with me a moment of of of
he's kind of satisfying because the person
interviewing with start of apologizing for
why he was to CVS code and I love you I love
it I think it's a phenomenal to I think
everybody should learn it but you know when
you want to take it up a notch a loan at
Terminal and and and and layer on some more
learning on there I think it's it's a good
time to do that that's that's really hot to
say about that I know it's our chat volumes
is as good as gone down a little bit and
that's why maybe we can actually talk I am
trying to put structure a wrap around all of
this and so we can do that I would ask that
you can read the about of our sight here so
that we can you know turn some things down
and you know there's there's there's all
kinds of things and we're going to
definitely have to get some mods if we're
going to have all of you in here at one time
this is quite an influx of of people we're
normally a very small community
of of of of people I want to put a plug in
for the community right here we are we've
got I'm going to brag can I brag Community
can I bring a little bit about the people
that are here
can I brag I got to brag on my community
members because this is this community and I
mean it I'm not just saying this is a this
is a pretty popular thing for twitch people
to say but I mean it I truly mean it the
community is what really makes our stream
work at and I am not going to I'm going to
be vulnerable here for it with you for a
moment I got my present job because of the
Stream
I'm not exaggerating I had been doing I've
been running my own company was very great
everything covid hit and and everything and
I realize that I was going to have to so so
Porsche what's a portion for example for
should you mind if I share with some of the
stuff that you shared on the stream before
is it okay can I share stuff that you've
docks before that I remember about you so
Porsche is one of the lead kubernetes
infrastructure engineer's and Architects for
one of the biggest investment banks in the
world
and here they are participating I don't know
what their gender is there anything and I I
would ask everybody to be very very
respectful of our identities there's some
other people in here I'm going to I'm going
to I'm going to give nods to our community
members who is here has been a regular
kubernetes presenter who has created
security reports that are being used by the
White House and has shaken the hand of the
present we have people in a proportionate it
is proportion to hear proportionate is is
here proportionate is another major cg.o in
a company that's very large that you would
probably know and that has regularly said
that they've been paid over $100,000 just
for single Consulting gigs my community is
is contains people who own independent
millionaire who I believe sold her business
is Chris Lopez.
Fantastic dreamer by the way if you want to
get into that I don't know which President
we will talk about that basically did the
people who come here I'm not trying to say
this to to brag about my people but I am I'm
bragging about that because they are the
ones they spend hours upon hours over here
with me struggling to learn how to run
how to run to Cooper Nettie's how to install
it what is it why do I give a shit and
they've taken me they'd taken me from not
knowing anything about get other than to how
to save stuff in Osage software I get to be
able to use get and do branching and stuff
like that to our community when I when I say
that we are cold Learning Community I mean
it because their main reason that I stream
as much as I do is because of how much I get
out of it and that's very selfish for you to
say it but I I mean it I literally have
gotten a job from live streaming and any of
you out there for beginners I'm going to I
mean I'm kind of talking here recycler
Bastian Baker at home I got we've been
having so much fun with that is so there's
been some other stuff yeah there any of you
who are just starting out here who don't
think that you should stream to Twitch I
want it I want to talk to you for a second
okay I'm going to actually assumed it if if
you think that you don't know enough to
stream you're wrong
because this is something I found of the
last eight years I paid Tas some of whom
were as young as 11 years old while I was
running still stuck in real life like in
person
I had right there were so young I couldn't
pay him it was illegal I had to give him I
had to give him discounts on their on their
tuition and I want to tell you something
they I watch them I watched how they taught
people that they would sit next to the
people who are paying money to be there and
we had a ratio of 1 to 3 and they would
spend the time explaining how to do python
explaining how to do you know where we go to
recognize Monty Python yeah this is one of
our mascots they would spend the time
explaining the bridge keeper program or or
Nyan Cat and I really like Leon's active
recalls up about that because I've been
doing that for a long time to we would code
we would code means you know you can say but
it did anybody know how to get the killer
rabbit in Minecraft did you know there's a
killer rabbit in Minecraft
raise your hand if you know that there's a
yeah they're totally is going to give it
away for you have to you have to you have to
you can find it if your bankruptcy and I'm
sort of closet Minecraft back is a lot of
kids one of the ways that we would teach
young people as we would have them start the
Minecraft servers in those people one of
them actually got his own interns working
for a solar energy company and ordered his
own boards that he soldered together from
China
so a good night everybody has to leave I
understand if you guys have to go I
appreciate you guys coming on in if anybody
feels like you need to go The Holy Hand
Grenade accept it down procedures to 5 or 3
or whatever so anyway I I just want to say
that you should stream you really should you
really should you don't need a fancy light
or background or anything like that you
should consider streaming and you should
stream in science attack and code or just
chatting I really really really believe that
I really believe that fact it was predicted
there would be a 60% increase this year I
think Bluebird predicted it in personal
broadcasting you know why because you other
people need to see that you are vulnerable
and willing to make mistakes on a string and
you know what you would be surprised you'd
be surprised getting docks with suck and I'm
okay with being. If you have any issues as
being docks I understand this and and I am
not I am not saying everybody knew
do the Syracuse people in certain careers a
certain situations for Tampa I would not
stream if my if I had young children at home
if I had young children at home I would not
be willing to stream and ice cream
everything i r l i got my skateboard
I got my skateboard over there if you want
it if you want to laugh your ass off you can
go see me you can go see me Wipeout on my
longboard on the YouTube video that got
clipped
I got called too fast I went down and I
think I cracked a rib
that's not on YouTube I've been skating
since I was 14 the longboard is just easier
for me to skate on now that's the bottom
line research destroy what should I stream
just stream you just stream you doing you
whatever it is you know it so and if that
means doing I don't block I write to my slow
cook a 65 blog is people think they've just
got to be good if you want to follow my blog
go over here and follow my get home
so that that's oh God are you go if my
ozello Caston is a method of note-taking
developed by Nicholas Lumen and you know
like the 1918 I think of something like that
and yes scared to die and it's it's my
method of no taking the reason I don't
publish that to the web is because I have
noticed it when I put stuff out on the web
people expect it to be good
as you can talk to
that's what separates Republican Tenney from
personal identity that's a tough question I
was actually mohacs in Second Life for years
and I had my identity was was totally you
know Anonymous and then a lot of ship went
down in my life and clean my horse and and I
I decided to go public on I'm more things so
capillary Curtis absolutely no age Gap
absolutely no age Gap is so save your life
I'm telling you me to Mike Mike please come
back and talk to me about that when there's
less chatter going on I I really want to
talk I started a company call Ed Tech
Retreat and we we help teachers get into I
was just I was kind of disillusioned with
working for corporate American IBM and and
and then I decided to reach out and I met a
bunch of teachers for Twitter and they
trying to help me get into teaching I
thought of summer camp for game development
in gamemaker if you've ever seen it we might
actually do a face
development class here then yeah and then
and then I moved to have solutely I didn't
even for an absolute phuc yea you kidding me
I work for toe for it do you know tell for
it
do you know teleport
and all the Ricks College Drop rather be
College dropouts alright old for it that's
where I was yeah yeah there's a great is a
great Hawaiian food place in in Portland by
the way a couple the streamers you face if
you just want to have fun right but I tend
to to do other stuff
so yeah I'm kind of all over the bar b b s s
life really really help to help me out and
help me out to learn a lot of stuff here at
Nike yea actually there's a really great you
guys know that the video for Portland
we have it somewhere are you sure my video I
made this fun little clip thing
what should we put on the clip I know which
one do we always do
it's working
the note-taking method is called
zettelkasten and and here's here's where you
can read about it I made videos about it
and I have a I have a tool that allows you
to acquire it those are the only things that
I have if you click on those links should be
able to read about it and I use that is that
is a tool that I had to go to do that by the
way I strongly encourage you not to like buy
a city or something but to like make your
own tools the power of Bosch is that you can
you can think of a tool like man I wish I
had a thing that did this in this in this
and you can make it in a weekend I mean. So
powerful scripting language is our weather
is Javascript or you know Basher note or
something and I love Oregon. I think it's
great only problem is you have to have you
Max right but that's the biggest from all
the things you should have used to make a
Bastrop to see what the current song is
actually do have that thank you for saying
so
yeah and I have I have another script called
live titles I made a script that allows me
to switch gears so I can change some fun
what can I I want to show off this I made a
script that you when you run the script it
actually changes the tags the category and
the title of your stream remotely in one
command and publishes and notifications to
Twitter and changes your status on on GitHub
in One Shot Ya
so it's like it's cuz it's the power of
Bashan curl you know look this is called
rapid application development you do is you
get shit that you want to work you get it
all worked out the way we want it and then
what then you make it into something that's
better like either as a web a progressive
web app I saw Leon talking about that the
other day or or you make it something even
more
something even more sustainable I can go you
write it and go or whatever your language if
your arrest person or whatever you know and
so this is this is all that code that
doesn't it actually has command line
completion built-in automatically any of the
commands that start with x. Automatically
get command line completion so I don't have
to walk around with that and that's that's
what's going on with the chat
and so yeah one weekend we made this tool
here you guys want it we could give you it
give her commands
what is it what is it called clip I think
that's it that's that we as a community we
made this one weekend this is say a command
line clip utility that will automatically
download the videos from YouTube put them in
your collection and then allow you to offset
the clips that you can play it anytime I
don't have any! Commands just yet
so this is for a 2000 remaster
yeah so you can you can have a look at this
you can give you
if anything if you want the Spotify this is
I'm currently running I'm currently just
running the radio off off the Cure I was I
was in kind of an 80s mood
I came in I was unexpectedly hardest to slap
me like that but I appreciate him doing it I
really do
I was just having fun I was just like
relaxing I just like $0.30 that's my third
beer you know
yeah I had to get verse of oxygen and give
it to Yo s okay so I'm going to take it
through that since y'all are here right
let's let's go for it since y'all are here
the rest of my crabs like only fuck I'm
never going to get him to hear me again
my regulars you got to understand my
regulars and I are really tight we're like
really really tight and I'm sure they're
here laughing their ass off in the
background right now right fisher fisher
fish you as one of my regulars
they're just laughing their ass off right
now
yeah I try to 34 how are you thought I was
lying and fardos yeah it's fine it's fine
it's it's good times
the Saturday to ask you to Shadow Legends
I'm I'm pretty lame boring guy I'm an
asshole to people hate me be careful people
hate me out there and switch that got
enemies man so I want to say okay it just so
you know the reason I'm an ass-whole is if
you do something that doesn't
if if you're lazy if you're intellectually
lazy I'm not going to let you have it unless
you have my most recent talk about this
drama okay what I want to put it out there
right now and right now I'm only bringing
this up because I want to set the tone for
this thing and I I want the town to be that
we don't talk about it, okay but I also want
you to know that that I am regularly an
asshole to people and usually not always but
usually there's two things that happen when
I'm an ass-whole the person either you've
been lazy and I'm trying to teach you a
lesson and I want you to go do the work
because you've been intellectually lazy and
you need to like step it up I've been asked
I've been asked what time it is before and
the time is like right there
you know it's like that I've gotten nicer I
got a nicer ass are doing yoga and drink a
beer and that is mean we all know that and
I'm definitely not a soul just rewards are
useless I think just a useless rates and in
the second reason I'm an ass-whole is is
when is usually a joke right like I'll say
that's the most erotic thing I've ever heard
it in on time I'm human and I fail all the
time I'm a condescending prick many times
and I apologize I apologize in advance
because I will probably say something that
will piss you off and and I have had people
say things that piss me off you know they've
talked down to me and I'm like well how dare
you know that I'm a human being I'm going to
make those mistakes I just want you to know
that sometimes I'm not in a good mood so he
said you like you're in a really good mood
right now this is awesome but I like OSHA
today and tomorrow rest is the best Steelers
Frank Franklin of our regulars and we fight
all the time and it don't nighttime out you
know people on occasion just because so we
can
stop ourselves from fighting with each other
and then they come back in the old things
are forgiven you know and and you understand
some of my best friends we call each other
morons all the time I don't mean
hyperbole but we can't do that I shouldn't
do that I know that but I don't want nobody
to feel feel like that that's that that's
you know I also feel like people should be
prepared for the industry unfortunately the
industry is full of pedantic assholes and if
you choose the lifestyle of Technology at
particularly like see development or Linux
or back and you know that kind of thing it's
not just a bro culture it it it tends to be
hard on you and if you don't believe me just
studying Linus Torvalds okay you know that's
all I'm going to say the TV's Academy we're
full Anubis we have tons of Orbeez in a
community I like talking about the people
who are socially lubricated what the fuck
all my regulars re4 Leon yes thank you
go easy on the beer exactly it's not too
much beer it's not too much beer but okay so
here's what you need to do if you want to
get ready if you want to get ready for the
Boost you just want to kind of have fun with
all of the stuff I would like the first
thing I would do I'm drinking a local it's
called it's called OMB copper if you know
it's a North Carolina beer I got some but we
shouldn't let them chase us away it right
yeah I agree so anyway so virtualbox just
the first thing you should download okay and
you should you should get this running on
your computer
and
well yeah I mean we're just I actually we're
just talking earlier about how we're going
to go to the cube come on in October next
year I'm getting ready to go and meet people
there and maybe some day present. I don't
know we'll see my focus is always been on
helping beginners get into technology and I
just seem to have focused more on the
infrastructure jobs in technology if you're
looking for a job let me let me give you the
breakdown from the Bureau of Labor is high
at the statistics on this let's go look at
this really quick really nice yeah I know
people in Detroit actually I thought about
moving there at one point yeah but I don't
know I don't like to see
Cinestar Savannah question I know and that's
that's pretty much my life I'm very OCD
I had a like all over the place and this is
just my problem I can have to get used to it
if I have to be making sure all right so
looking for jobs this is the statistics from
2021 from the Bureau of Labor Statistics in
America and not only are these the fastest
growing jobs in Tech they are the fastest
growing jobs. Is an interesting job that I
admitted here it's I think it's wind turbine
technician and as I would really fast
growing job as well if you don't have a
degree you're not screwed no you're not you
actually aren't I'm going to say something
it's so employment is about trust
and I love that Leon says it's only on one
day when he was getting ready to prepare and
I cannot believe all the amazing things you
said that I agree with one of the things he
said was they just want to hire somebody who
could do the job
that's totally true and you also said you
know get rid of those certificates or
anything like that it's more about proving
you can do the job and yeah so you know if
are actually made a whole video about
certificates if you want to go see I spend
the night even put a hold of him for the
whole diagram in there so you can go watch
that if you want to go see that this
certificate question is more complicated
when you get into infrastructure engineering
you like for example would you ever go to
which would you want your ambulance driver
to not have you know an EMT license probably
not right so that's the one extreme and then
over on the far far Other Extreme it would
you want your Java programmer to have I mean
I don't program drug would you want your job
at this time using this because this was
actually a huge argument of Korra between
Gail who wrote cracking the coding interview
and some other people I was a big argument
about whether you need two certificates for
software engineers
and their conclusion was what is software
engineer mean it means you're a developer
then he'll know you don't need a certificate
you should have tons of tons of code to
prove you know how to do it and so that's
the other end right so on the one hand you
have like electricians in people who have to
have a certificate in you have the other end
you have
you have the other end you have people that
if you have a certificate a kind of means
that you think certificates are important
for Java and obviously they're not so that
actually might even work against you because
why the fuck was you get a certificate if
you could just write code in reading through
it and that's where the ants coming from but
when Leon says you don't need a certificate
that's what he's saying and he even said and
I remember even said that's for software
development but there are other careers
where's our vacation makes a difference and
the closer you get to engineering to true in
theory right you know till like electrical
engineering and computer engineering
infrastructure engineering that kind of
thing the closer you get to those kind of
things worked hard to prove that you know
what you're going to do can't just put it
with your GitHub of repose right because you
might have even been written that much, just
like it if you did it's about your bathroom
pulse right right right you don't have a lot
of stuff to prove that you know. He's so at
that point it's kind of time to start the or
or or hacking you're going to be a hacker
for the government you have to have
certificates going to be a pain test if
United States government you have to have
so so I got its kind of a tangent but I
think it's really important that you that
you do have those kind of things but these
are the top careers in America according to
Bureau of Labor Statistics developer I
believe that they they lumped web developer
in was suffered to go over there was a 10%
changed between 2020 and 2021 he goes
through the years and and this opportunity a
number jumped up and the web developer
number went down and I'm almost positive I
don't have any proof of this but I've been
following the stats from year to year for a
while and I think the reason that that
happened is a bunch of web developers
suddenly qualify themselves as friend and
Engineers or front end developers if they
qualify themselves under the supper to Wilma
category writing electron apps and stuff
like that even if you might not like
electron that's what they started doing it
so they they they started putting himself in
the summer to go for category I think it is
important to note that the web that the
windmill for category here is by far the
fastest to get is still increasing
it's the fastest to get the salaries
probably an old number again it's a median
number from the United States government let
you know in comparison with four-year degree
kinds of stuff to do and I don't even think
you need this is this is going to be but I
think it's the equivalent of schooling right
and this is the closest when I can see there
is it there's a job here that's not covered
and that's and that's kubernetes
infrastructure cloud-native engineer in the
median salary for a clear up cloudy
eventioneers 150k median salary was it again
the median salary for doing what I'm doing
right now professionally as an
infrastructure engineer is $150,000 most of
the people that I know that her my age that
have been doing it's not devops most of the
people that I know that are doing my job
right now easily are making over 200,000 I
was offered 250,000 on paper for doing the
same job that I'm doing right now
and at the time I didn't take it because I
was running still sick I felt like I wanted
to finish that I was kind of stupid I would
have been flying around the France giving
presentations to self but whatever so I
chose to stay with the community and
eventually had to get a job anyway because
of covid and stuff so when I tell you I'm
not I don't I don't just want you to get a
job I want you to get the best possible job
that you qualify for that is a tech job so
if you know if if you want to get a tech job
and I know something out there are more
greedy than others and that's fine
I'm pretty sure I love you and I'll give you
the job for the money and give you a sense
of this I do it before sheet for this
company for a year and we bought a new car
for cash
today because of the money is just insane
it's just insane in this career I have a
recruiter I'm not even kidding I have a I
have a recruiter it's not easy work but it's
recording it's very hard work and it you
don't just think that you're going to do
like like you know three weeks of a boot
camp for give you a call to go out get
another $50,000 job you might chances are
you're not though chances are you're not my
type of my Fishel titles infrastructure
engineer at so I'm an infrastructure
engineer for high performance cluster doing
machine learning running kubernetes so
there's multiple layers of skills that are
getting paid for my experience and Bubba
blah and I'm actually I'm actually kind of
low and comparatively we have people in this
chat right now who probably won't give
themselves up you are making easily over
300K
what how long does it take to build
how long does it take to build the steel
stack the set that's funny because I called
it still stack right I think that you can
learn the skill set to do this within a year
of dedication and again the other thing they
are not like that Leon says is that you
don't have to learn it all to get the job
right let me give me an example of that so I
had zero knowledge of Darker and other than
knowing what it was at zero knowledge of
doctor I had zero cavities experience zero
knowledge of Darker and $0 if you were
Daddy's I had never even done I could even
describe what it was and I was hired as a
kubernetes machine for any engineer and I
told him in the interview I told it was a
company that you would know if I said it
please don't talk to me it was in the
interview I said I want you to know I have
no experience and capabilities and I have no
experience in in Darker but I other than the
things I've been playing with a home
and they said that's fine you can learn it
they told me that there's a whiteboard
interview is that so is so and what I'm
trying to tell you is and then a year later
and I I really really immerse myself in
communities tonight I've had people in
Industry who who know what's up tell me that
I'm you know, comparative Lee I'm advance at
this point cuz I've been putting a lot of
time I want to tell you that you can do it
you can definitely go step-by-step and learn
something every week and and set yourself up
to do it no wife for interview at all they
just looked at my CV they looked at my
experience it looked at my stuff in my repo
they looked that they talked to the person
who recommended me and the person who
recommended me said you'd be a fool for not
hiring this guy the way to get the job and
Leon will tell you about this to the way to
get the job is to meet people you're going
to you're going to get a job people are
going to give you the jobs about building
trust it's not about showing a sign of cold
calling somebody or spending a ton of
resumes I will never get you a job the thing
is going to get you a job
is meeting people meeting people at meetups
meeting other novices and conventions
meeting people on Twitch streams like this
going to Leon's desk or going to my Discord
going to anybody's disc or making community
members of every single job I have gotten
has been become because of a human
connection I had with somebody not because
of some cold call
I just got it yeah it's in here it's in my
mouth but
yeah here it is well we sometimes do that
are Porsche Porsche grease that's great I
love it when people back me up on this who
actually know what's up a box of hypervisor
at work I asked that question I've been
using I just been playing around hyper kid
on Mac trying to compare the two I have you
in my Pro I have a Premiere Pro license I've
been using for years I just actually just
wrote about this
and I believe the best first Linux on
virtualbox at a a justification for that
so here's a my justification for saying that
did you guys get that
so that should give you a copy
of what I think virtualbox I used to have
people there a doctor and do for in Linux
that way you look at me when I say First
Lenox experience I'm talking about primarily
your first Linux terminal experience even
though virtualbox allows you to try a bunch
of stuff out right unless you use a lot of
stuff I was playing Dota 2 and an n and
doing gamemaker which is Windows only
technology 2013 on a Linux machine using
VMware Pro because it had you pass through
back then and the technology for
virtualization is pretty amazing nowadays so
you know you can you can kind of do that for
corsages yes here it is
boost the Boost it's actually
I just realized that I need to update the
calendar it's off right now just remember
one date May 4th at 11 11 11 May 4th at 11
11 11 is when we're going to begin you're
welcome to come here every single Saturday
between noon and 5 is dedicated to begin our
content will be doing creative stuff now cuz
it kind of the End Cycle and that every
Sunday from from noon from noon to 3 or so.
I saw them canceled cuz I go around places
we do art as soon as I would do art
galleries or something is AMA is that same a
time and I noticed you're out the raid him
sometime during that time
during that time learning how to learn his
name of the game absolutely it's a question
here and by the way if you haven't got it
set up yet but if those are you have
specific questions you put a q in front of
them eventually I'll be able to filter those
out and I'll be able to get your questions
easier I don't have that filter set right
now but at some point I'll be able to do
that and May 4th she is at Easter day ever
fear eastern Time is what is going to be
whatever my time is
so is your son a question I came from Leon I
took it around your Twitter just kind of
contest what's the best way to become part
of community content-wise 2021 booster red
YouTube If you if you want to get going
through so jazzed up and you want to get
going right now you can go ahead and do all
42 days of the beginner booze from 2022 so I
just sent out that stuff if you follow the
link on that there's a there's a playlist of
my YouTube I want to tell you something up
before you get it I got to warn you okay I'm
going to zoom in for this I am a random
wandering guy I am not if you're if you're
if you're looking for hyper organized
hyper-focus hyper edited well-edited content
this is not the place I'm messy I'm messy
and I personally I think learning is messy
so is sometimes I'll have a group of 8 10
people in there and I'm like hey let's try
this out and all I can't let's try this out
hey let's try this. We're totally off the
rails
that's just how I am I like that that's my
style of learning to me learning is lab is
like a lab it's very messy it's very it's
very chaotic it's like I want to follow this
and that that's why the web works right
there while we work you're not not we have
to do and we're going to be next in 20 20 20
20 two are definitely in a cup of Ruby are
going to come retrieve it but it's only a
boost by the way a boost means that I'm
going to show you enough to know what you
don't know and then send you on your way and
we'll do some of that together most of the
work is going to be your time there's so
much content out there to learn we don't
have enough time to go in-depth it anything
and I really like that Leo does Leon goes
very in-depth into things I think it's
fantastic I really like that I wish I had
the time I don't because I got so much, so
we're going to cover 12 languages and I'm
not kidding we going to cover and you think
I caught a polyglot programming we're going
to learn to code in 12 languages
and if we like will a Jason's not a language
I beg to differ yes it is we're going to
learn to code in marketown Json yemil Tamil
I made the logo for, by the way I have to
say every time what books did Lennox in the
meantime learning least give me online it's
free and there's no rust here no there's no
rush you know why rust is not an
infrastructure engineering language yet it
will be it's just not yet we're going to
Basco python ribbing for all these are
essential learning if you want to do this
job there are over twenty thousand lines of
pearl that I have to maintain that I adopted
from I don't have maintained its not my
specific job but not knowing how to go to
Pearl and Reed Ruby you might think it's an
old school thing I like most of the code
that's going to get you a high-paying job is
written in Ruby Pearl and Java
and if you don't like it you know take some
Silicon Valley job where everything's all
Greenfield and they're all doing rest or
something but actual work that's paying
that's what they're paying for you to do you
still transfer the absolutely I'm doing
cloud-native so the community stuff I'm
doing is I'm building a cloud on Prem and
all of their Community skills directly apply
to Cloud wherever you're going to do the
club it's just so on from cloud-native it's
called cloud-native means that were using
Cloud technology whether or not it's a cloud
provider or we're doing it for a big
monsters company with 200 machine learning
people doing jobs everyday so and I that's
what money is by the way
nobody said to pick up and he's that are
paying to do their own clouds so so yeah I
can go back as soon as yourself to Lenox if
you're just getting started okay I sent it
as a lot of people are really anxious to get
going and I want you to have something to
start so let me give you some homework I
guess okay the first thing you need to do is
get Lennox and the fastest way to get
lennox's to install virtualbox right so you
install Oracle virtualbox is not working
they bought them you sell virtualbox okay
that's the first thing to do and if you
and if you want to 22 videos I said
something different I said the fastest way
is to install Docker desktop and I just did
an article today about why I'm changing that
Docker desktop is no longer free and I
believe in free software so I'm pushing
virtualbox also over two bucks will get you
other Advantage later I wrote about those
today if you want to read about them you can
give you more forever be fine yeah if you
can invest to be a further be fine to there
they're all good
I love you my bro but virtualbox is fine
another advantage of her tool boxes that the
driver for it in vagrants so I have a I have
a program this is protocol vagrant which
spins up three machines in like 5 minutes
and then you can work on multiple machines
at the same time it's not something for
beginners but that's something that is
driven by virtualbox primarily so it's only
called a retreat at your second thing you
need to do if you're going to start this
stuff up the second thing you need to do is
you need to install Linux right so how do
you do that actually I'm going to show you
it's not even that hard so let's actually do
and right now I was at 20 because I was
actually getting ready to do this install so
I have virtualbox installed
I'm running pop OS which I hate him and
complaining about like crazy and probably to
get off of it so here's virtualbox I got all
these virtual machines that were built for
me hey you want to run Windows here we go
let me show you click on start there's
Windows 11 for free just to show you the
point
and I was I was actually testing this
because I read an article that said it
didn't work anymore
you download it you download evaluation
version for free
yeah it if you just search for Windows
Windows virtualbox you will find it and you
can just download it
but I don't push pause on YouTube it's too
hard work if I could figure out how to do
that automatically I would do it
just get into our hearts Ginger Archer for
people who are really hard who want to learn
Linux in the low-level and that's fine that
is absolutely fine if that's something you
want to do it's not something that I care to
do well that just boo did you see that green
screen
that's interesting
it did it blue screens and updates are
underway keep your computer on 35% I'm
upgrading my Windows machine which is not a
Windows machine
I thought you know what I used to like my
jaro until I had nine-year-olds click on
upgrade and and it break their computer and
they cried
and I was like what the fuck I am not a fan
of my journal
because of that I'm in not to mention
they've tried to push business software on
people
arches if you if you look I don't generally
recommend Arch to beginners here's the
really great thing you don't have to pick
you can try them all and make your own
decision you can be you can be your own
person you can make your own decisions you
don't have to let some Arch asshole yell at
you and tell you you suck because you didn't
learn Arch
you can go you can install the operating
system's you want you don't have to take
distro tubes word for it or anybody else you
just go install it and you make your own
decision how about that
because you are an individual you know it's
like you don't you don't have to to listen
to these people clean me
now it if you ask me and I used to be very
pathetic as it because I was so sick and
tired of beginners trying art and screaming
and leaving Linux because they Rage Quit
like somebody said that I actually got mad
and I'm like fuk know it's so and I
recommended Linux Mint to people as my
primary and I still do think that's probably
one of the better ones and then Bible claim
number one of my early community members two
years ago came in and said you know you
should try Papa's it's a lot easier. Right
now it's not know so argumentative and then
I tried that like oh my God this is awesome
and tell it wasn't it within the last month
populace has gone really downhill and and I
and I find myself trying other Linux distros
or anticipated the cool thing is is it again
we're not using Linux least I'm not using
the next as my primary desktop operating
system if you want to do that I am right now
right now I have his populist but I'm
considering switching over its don't let
anybody make you feel like you're less of a
human being because you're not running loose
on your desktop or you're not doing this or
that or that you're your own person
and you can learn Linux without that you can
keep your favorite gaming machine and you
can still learn Linux
right if you don't have the budget to split
it up if you're going to school and you only
have one computer and you have to decide I
want to make sure it's always works as a
real look at this
where does 11 just just crapped out hey take
care of everybody if you're taking care if
you're leaving
I know I don't like when it's 11 either I I
know I don't like it I hate 11 firstly I
wanted to see how far this thing would get
with for it died
the reason it's dying by the way is because
guess what
when is 11 can't run Docker inside of it
inside of a virtual machine that's what I
was testing I've downloaded Windows here so
I could try it favorite pencil is good to
it's actually great for programming
at so this time I kill this I don't give a
shit about this goodbye but I want to say
it's a power off the machine right okay
you're done but what I'm trying to tell you
is if you if you do want to go with Lennox
is your daily driver you can still get
Windows if you have an application that
needs it like SolidWorks or something I'm
going to run quickly and if it's a gaming
thing you might want to be aware of
something that has GPU pass-through
otherwise you're not going to get hit with
performance penalties although I game I play
Witcher which is a Windows only thing
without a problem on your end that's another
thing I swing by the way I stream Witcher
and ice cream Dota 2 I play 32 in which her
a lot so and I ice cream art things to I got
our calories and stuff kind of variety stuff
and walks and long runs a ice cream 25k
around Thanksgiving which I need to do again
I'm getting fat again God damn it and any
other Runners out there
any other Runners I've been streaming
running lately thanks for the fall
I've been streaming running lately because
it's been such a such a thing right here we
are going to do yeah so we're going to make
a new computer here if you guys got to run
come back I'm here all the time so don't
worry we got raided
the Striking were running it's technically
or clinics there you go
there's lots of them is that I see you when
I see you. We wish it in the picture is not
risking his ability to reason. Is she at the
you know yet
look at the church or at least not at at
least at least not soon as it's supposed to
say or do you want a further what is super
clear the shows of how do you build New York
City Block Apartments where I also received
one or two courses shy of a French major and
I've lived in France and Russia for a
significant amount of time as a cruise
director and a travel agent
in Russia and I was I was I lived in the end
and hung out on the Caribbean and met a lot
of rastas I was actually a Mormon missionary
in the French Caribbean I'm no longer Mormon
at your school right there so I was just
trying to tell you I do not speak Italian I
wish I don't have any Asian languages under
my belt and I don't have any time but I
really really really really love is it true
absolute absolute the Russians made the
under under Nikolai they made the Russians
made the official language French for the
entire fucking country when they move the
capital to see the pit Petersburg in Russia
or that's the way extreme yeah yeah let
people hear no my more relaxed trust me
we'll talk about it some time
yeah if you're Mormon night I'm not trying
to disparage you I am going to make a lot of
jokes at the expense of Mormons because I
feel like I earned the right but you know I
don't want you to feel personally offended
for you
expertise Minister yeah
and we try to keep it pretty still around
here but we can talk about that stuff it's
kind of interesting it does you fucking
interest so but just drive safe but it's
with a French accent because you're pissed
you got it fixed if I was your dubs
conditioners I look at you go wait wait wait
wait I'm not understand that y'all are y'all
or y'all are funny
all right there we go we got it we got it
installed yeah alright next step to you're
going to install
is it raining but not raining do I have the
rain sounds on still I have the rain sounds
on
I'll turn the rain sounds off I'm sorry
stream is alive today it really is a
selfless about ya body
just wanted to tell you if it was your post
I sent to kiss you
to get surprises
get back on that awesome
Grandma we have a number of people that are
going to be in here yeah that's a good
friends yeah Jim's not around right now it
doesn't look like we have met people that
are in Canada Canada and Genesis in Toronto
actually kiss each other for a long time
can I jump when I was in the Caribbean we
learned we were not so you can Creole which
is a which is a form of French Pepsi and Mae
West and that's all yeah alright I'm kind of
this is really fun
you like just Mary Jane
Hey I just heard since pretty awesome then
they are again I'm getting away with this
because why please no one telling me no one
telling me but I know what I feel like I'm
Justified because switch made it twitch made
at which person committed committed the
change to OBS to allow turning off track to
which eliminates the music the music from
the boss of everybody listen to this water
right now like when it comes when I go back
to watch the repeat in the lot and there's
no music in it I just can't have my voice
and that's it there me what you know
started jumping rope oh yeah it was great if
you're stuck when I was a missionary I jump
rope everyday and it was fantastic because I
couldn't leave my companion the side because
it was against Mormon rules to do that
the stream yeah go to sleep guys do what you
have to do the gang and I are going to have
to get it together here we're going to do
some we need some moderators of stuff
if we're going to have this kind of
population here which is fine I hopefully
you guys will spread the word
oh I will send it when I get back when I was
more into it's so have you met with a gray
just cuz I'm a pretend like I just want to
try it out by the way there's no shame and
using Linux with a gooey to get used to what
you might want to run on your desktop one
day write this is this is where you want to
mess with this right either that or get an
old computer and just do it the hard way so
if you a bunch of mint is Ubuntu right yeah
a thanks for saying so
I figured it bad for like a month interested
no I can't really understand what's going on
oh yeah we're going to talk about it a lot
we're going to win the jump into it and
actually I've been using for the last four
days Abby I like doing cold working and
stuff so I'm I just learned a few days ago
if so maybe you can help me I'd be sure to
help me out
my biggest fear is getting an M1 Mack is
because of all the all the incompatibilities
with all the container stuff and I'm really
worried about it I so I'm super interested
in what you all have to say about that
you know so we can figure things out but
you're pushing for the Go Go Gophers backup
oh here's our plushies we're big plushies
fancier Maz UK bought me this actually we
call it he's his name is Mozzy now it says
this is when I get really frustrated I have
to get the plushies out I have to cuz I I'm
I get too uptight about it
I get I get to a type yeah go to bed early I
might be around I might have to extend
myself what time is it
a sedated of tools of 11:00 yeah
yeah right to create a virtual hard disk yes
10 gig hard drive will just use the
standover toolbox one super easy to handle
the alligator that means it doesn't show up
10 to go home once
and then what we could have been be a d file
allocation create
and now we have a machine it's not on so we
have to start it up to double click on it
and it's like it sends me this thing over
here I'm sorry for the following
notifications I I I I am inexperienced with
this level of following so so here we go so
it's like startup yes how's it going to
Anita so here we go startup startup with
Selective startup disk alright we're going
to click on
start but we not going to that until we pick
what we want to start right so what is an
ISO what did I just download the thing you
downloaded is the same exact ones and zeros
that would be on a USB stick were you to put
that stick in a computer and boot from it to
install Linux it's the same thing it's
exactly the same thing so you're going to
come in here and you're going to say I need
to attach another volume six on add to go
poking around here why are you starting my
VM I didn't find anything yet
I didn't say I wanted to do that one yet
we're doing it
I think it's getting kind of overzealous on
me like I was in a Timeout or something
come on oh no now it's not happy
here we go so I need to go find it where is
it's in my it's on my desktop it's in my eye
so images of swear I downloaded it to
Vigor and said we're going to do bacon bits
he's a big interest here right we're going
to definitely use vagrant get the difference
between vagrant a vagrant actually doesn't
it but not by default sounds like we have
somebody knows what's up so I talked to them
for a bit so that Ona says it's a dishonest
or Thomas vagrant does not which is nice
right and it's super easy to do but they
have to learn Ruby up front so we talked
about absolute beginners here right and so
I'm learning how to use a GUI for your first
time it's probably worth doing so that I
downloaded and I so literally stands for the
iso format for a CD Once Upon a Time these
things were CDs are going to bed guys and
gals so we're going to choose that and then
we're going to load that up I'm just this is
just a preview for those are you still here
akali already
nice and it goes start that up fell to open
a session for virtual machine meant who I
wonder why it didn't like it for some reason
but there we go start Linux Mint
and that I that I am I so soft after yes you
remember that I was up I was like I do
I wish I could turn the flower stuff I
haven't figured out how to do it I don't I
turn my alert box off and it still makes the
noise so I don't know what to do with that
alright so here we go here we have mint
close this up
and now this doesn't this is an actual mint
right this is just the mounted version of
meant so you can go through and see and I
can learn about it and stuff and open the
terminal and customized I want to show you
is if if you have ya go to streamlabs I did
I went to the streamlabs I went all the way
to the same website and try to disable
alerts and it didn't work apparently it
cashes them all yesterday I got I got I got
bought attacked yeah so if you go here you
can come here and you can say
I got cinnamon cinnamons my favorite but
what I'm trying to tell you so you can
actually do full screen with this
yeah chick full screen mode this is insane
all right so it's telling you be careful cuz
you're going to forget how to go back so you
have to push the whole staff right those
keys currently defined as the right control
can you can we make sure I know what that is
okay right here alright so and so watch I'm
going to go into full-screen mode
now fortunately this screen resolution has
not synchronized with with my actual screen
resolution which you can fix what I'm trying
to tell you is that with virtualbox your
screen turns into Linux
and unless you're doing like really high
performance seems like an even even that
could be fixed it's the same so what do you
have a Mac or you know any think you can try
every single Linux distro on planet Earth
and make your own decisions about what you
want to use
so this is how we downloaded Lennox the way
we downloaded Linux is we went here
let me see which one is it is it Angus is a
controller
there's a h i can't remember which one it is
it told me I can't remember
it traded for me too and I get my mind's
already gone come on guys canceled it was
working and I just I got it wrong
so it's a viewing of you and get out of
full-screen mode
and so it was a redhead proportion to how
are you I was talking about you actually
is it right is right control uh yeah so this
is what I did and I went and got Linux by
going to Linux Mint and downloading the iso
image the disk image and when I say this
because this is the second the same thing as
if you had an old school CD but we don't do
anymore and it's the kind of thing you would
write to a USB stick and we will cover that
infrastructure engineering but we're not
going to do that in the beginning because
you can just use a virtual machine for now
but if you can do the same thing and go out
to Cali Lenox right love people like it
re4 Leon yet so you can go get Kali Linux
and the most advanced pentesting blah blah
blah download
ever fighting I so yeah I mean you can do
all those steps and you can get you know
whatever kind of calibration you can get a
virtual machine directly if you don't want
to hear some machine that you don't have to
go through the install steps I can do with
mint at and you could just go get that
affect my download that right now I'm just
goes so I'm going to download this is
download this 3.7 GB will take a while but
it's an OVA file which means it's already
exported virtualbox image so it just have to
start it up enough to install anything it
just starts up it's just like if you woke up
an image I woke up a computer and a few
hearty ones that are still hanging hanging
out a co-worker versus day coronavirus
United used to tell Jay to be in
if your nose 100 singles would you go sell
my god when is 60 pixelated
it doesn't add a message via three sides but
I got to tell you right away I am not the
best I have now the best of that you know
why because I don't give a shit eventually
this is for beginners to try out right but
it
try out right but it but I am at mr.
terminal guys so my first thing as soon as
vagrants I do vaguely just for you I might
actually show you what I've been doing with
this. Is it all in a meat let me sort of our
more advanced use it sounds like we have a
few more advanced people here if you don't
mind I'd like to just show up to them a
little bit so yeah yeah I'm going to be here
until then if you just want to hang out or
whatever but if you have questions about
this stuff can I get prepared but the 4th is
going to be organised it's it's going to be
more organized at least as organized as I
ever get
lost w h yeah well it's okay so here's your
doctor well that's the thing okay if you
watch the booster 2021 we learn the Linux
terminal using docker
at only doctor we used all the docker
desktop and did it that way
and previously I'd use Virtual machines are
actually installs and I'm returning in 2022
to going through the virtual machine
approach for lots of reasons thank you
everybody looks like we got our
our group is going to call me down which is
good so to those out there who want to know
about virtual machines and why they matter
I'm about to do some stuff that's kind of
advanced and this is one of the reasons that
I believe virtual machines are important is
because even though you know you're going to
do the virtual machine in the desktop kind
of thing that's not the most important
reason to learn verse machine at the most
important reason is and I have my lab here's
my lab the lab is like all the random shit
that I'm working on it's a repo that
constantly and getting messed with an
incomplete and everything like that I don't
have any kind of slides for set up nope I
don't have any are talking about or talk
about setting up virtualbox
yeah it's pretty it's pretty easy
by the way we don't we tell always listen to
80s music sometimes we listen to we usually
order listen to chill up here just so you
know sometimes I go heavy industrial on
occasion just cuz I haven't you know a while
to air it will do like sometimes will do
like reggae sometimes will do we just an
Appalachian stuff the other day that was
pretty awesome
all right so sit here we go we've got
I said if this I've been trying so my job is
to it's a run for Nettie's oh I haven't
heard of that one
add I'm a big music fans in fact that I've
been down to have a car today my wife bought
a car sitting on my phone car which means I
have my own car now so now I can start going
down the road so you can see a lot of
variety streams I'm going to be at pubs
write in code and live streaming like live
music I already did when I did one in
December and I had to stop because it covid
in because of the car was gone and I'm going
to be doing that a lot more and we're going
to go give you typing speed is not important
don't stress about it you should probably
learn too stupid to die properly and and
then go go from there
yeah okay so
signature distro for a while I think Linux
Mint and Papa was a great distress for your
first destroyed but as I said you don't need
either of them if you're going to learn the
terminal first all right I sent him the one
that we got with cinnamon I prefer cinnamon
but everybody's got their own preference so
do you think how far is craft beer let's go
back to
I surmise you know it so my Old-Timers this
reminds me of when we did this the hacking
May 4th strain we had like three four
hundred people that died that day and we had
to deal with different issues because so
many people were here and it got really hard
to focus on people I like it it's a good
problem to have but but it's going to be
interesting
alright so so here's here's a good example
of when do you use a virtual machine so I
don't know I don't know if Jonas is still
there they say her name right I know. I'm
still here but this is this is fucking
amazing this is what it is by the way LBG
he's not here right now by giving up with
you all the credit LBG kind of tutored me
through how to do all this and I cannot
overstate my gratitude and if you want this
file I give it to you is a program
colleagues from the command line then we'll
send you the whole
really great thing about exes I can take
this little number here and I can be editing
a file and I can do this I can do eakes file
number and I can send that to bashing I can
replace that line with the entire file from
the internet
cuz Lenox cuz Bosch caziques little video on
eggs if you want to see it it's phenomenal
is way better than basement it's a thousand
times better and so they want to cut his
career advice I can give you is to follow
the Boost that's my take on it advice I
actually did the begin reducing I do it
every year and I'm going to be doing another
one this year in 2022 I'm getting ready for
it trying to keep it as more organized as
possible and so here's the vagrant file
so this is the stuff that anybody who knows
bigger you might not know about this there's
some experimental volume directors you can
give the snow Ruby code which we will learn
during the Boost previous one of them is
going to learn
foreign languages at the same time I call it
the polyglot approach during a boost we're
going to quickly learn briefly learn the
major parts of four languages at the same
time where do pythons go and Ruby and those
are the major infrastructure languages see
is another good one yeah it just blew me
away somebody told me about it on stream
actually it's one of those many things that
somebody on the stream told me about it and
we just shared it as a community so
the thing I like about you the most is it
you can I need to give you the stew
I need to I need to eat you I need to give
you a kiss as well this is my
translation of it if they had their own but
you can go and look at that one and see if
you want to modify that allows you to use as
a filter so you can use it from within VI
and just send certain lines to people like
you just want to send like two lines for
your majesty to somebody you just select
those lines and pipe it to eakes on the
filter and then they just get it they just
get your own pretty fucking awesome actually
what I saw that I was like glued sex hell
yeah so look for me alright I'ma Do My Own
Thing don't be ashamed of researching things
there's a stigma against looking shit up
because that it makes you less of a person
or something like that it comes from the
repressive educational institutions that are
documented very well and call that very well
in a in a book from Paula Ferry call
pedagogy of the oppressed which talks about
this make her salad acacian where they want
to keep the other learning in the hands of
the teachers than what everybody else to sit
there open their head and taking the data
and Baker style education as he calls it
it's if you wanted watch it twice crack has
got an amazing deep or dumb video about Bill
and Ted's Excellent Adventure where they
talk about Paula freestyle of education and
they actually make a positive possibility
that Bill and Ted is actually very deep
because of the way the George Carlin teaches
Bill and Ted is completely through
experiential learning he gives them he sets
up the opportunities to learn them and then
he gets out of the way
ever notice that
you ever notice that about Rufus Rufus on
Bill and Ted he sets up the experiences for
them to learn and then he leaves that's
Prairie and learning that's experiential
learning that's practical learning and I'm
very much a practical person very icy just
recently wrote a is that a cast in The Block
if you will about this very thing so don't
let anybody tell you that looking stuff up a
fun story about this I had 8 people in my
school and I had it it's a pet it's an old
one you got a very dense
it took me a long time to read it follow
ferreri
yeah and so if you guys would really love
wisecrack wisecrack did a a deeper down on
it and it is absolutely amazing and it's
really great just know that that book was
written in the sixties so it's got some
really really intense misogynistic you know
toxic masculinity in it and unfortunately I
hate it but if you can stand that and that
book is quoted a lot in educational Realms
and stuff I'm not a teacher or not formally
trained I just
not formally trained I just read a lot and
and that's why it wasn't the other one is
Sir Ken Robinson is out of their minds in
this is all stuff I cover on the first day
of the Boost usually
if if the
out of our minds it's it's absolutely when
the most important Works about education
creativity you ever read also the kid
Robinson is hilarious is TED talks to her
absolutely totally hilarious yeah so so this
is our story so I'm I'm teaching a bunch of
kids mostly like 8 or 9 of them in my my
humble little skill stack Mentor Community
we lived in a town home and I was underneath
that you can actually go see the townhome if
you want to go to the Instagram on skill
sack if you want to kind of get a visual of
this to go with my old story and you see if
I can find it
yeah so I just to give you a sense this is
what I I started some years back 2013 that's
Charter Community this is before we moved
yet or no man and everything so so here's
that's what actually is already know which
way it's been in here is he here now which
often cause right now but yeah so we had
this little community and this is my this is
my son in the content and I'm, I'm teaching
on Saturdays is is an evolution of the same
kind of paddleboards as being the paddle
boarding and so yeah we wouldn't be in here
right so just imagine there was it was a
class who this is game night this whatever
is playing games and Ben's got his 3D got a
Oculus on and
we would be a really great because we have
all these Misfits come from all over our
community and come join in this nice warm
out is fair on Friday and Saturday nights
and play games and geek out together and go
get Swedish fish from from Food Lion and it
was just really fun having great memories of
it one time when I was teaching class in
after I know it's very Lo-Fi know if Abbey
school did he really
think I'll see it now montessaurus you die
like huge fan of Montessori Montessori
actually does a lot of the same stuff and I
just happen if I think I think if you hadn't
most people if they're very know how to
learn and they've been served beating out of
the normal method of learning and they don't
do it anymore and it kind of forgotten how
they forgotten how to allow themselves to be
flexible and vulnerable to fail to reach out
into research for things and they're being
punished for researching and they're being
forced to be competitive because the grades
and there's like a billion influences that
really fucked you up and so anyway all these
people in there and I said okay to talk
about whatever for python for loose or
something like that we were teaching by the
back then tell me what little boys and
one of these days like snarky smart-aleck
guys in like the middle row right about
where this guy was started Googling it is
real big screen TVs right he started
Googling it on the big screen TV and
everybody could see any had this like evil
Grinch grin like and then he turned around
got the answer it read it off Wikipedia and
set it out loud raised his hand and said out
loud and it like you know and then he was
like all Hacker about it right
and there's a girl I'm sorry it's just
that's that's her gender I'm just telling
she was right there and she said she she
turned she raised her head she goes that's
not fair that's not fair that's not fair he
Google
and I said yeah you did it faster than you
didn't he
and she was like so in deflated and I felt
so bad and yeah I know it's like and we all
laughed about it and you know I went to
release it looking now thank you for saying
so I know you mean well but the point of it
is that yeah 3/4 of the job is Google it's
Google how we want to do and y'all haven't
seen this yet but all my Google photos on
the command line so I don't know what's
yours for what is kubernetes all right let's
do that for the command line I do all my
searches from the command line because it's
like 10 to 20 times faster the graphic
browsers if I need a graphics browser I
push, and I got to grab a browser pulls up
the page for me
and I can find shit in microseconds that Ms
that takes a people like that I'm just
saying anybody who gets into this kind of
thing can can really learn
can really learn a lot and you can like
samples through this stuff and you can get
to think your eyes are able to read all of
the words at the same level you don't have
it what was the biggest problem when
scanning for Content we are trying to
research things is all the variation find
everything and I think it's important to
note that the original internet didn't allow
you to change the font or the colors or
anything
I mean not for a single page add ladder to
change it as a reader for everything is more
like a Kindle because the focus was on
content consumption it wasn't on content
creation and and we watch that and I'm
actually trying to build a new internet
called and I was exchanged grid that allows
the exchange of markdown files and you know
primarily text Data with raster image is so
if you're going to be a part of that it's a
separate issue that we're still trying to do
it Sunday call the knowledge exchange rate
otherwise known as keg I just re-read
recertified check out of sage and and that
is a real effort I'm sorry I was the
essential web my meant the kids and I meant
or tonight we would like hey what did we
need to make a a kick-ass web that doesn't
that's this built for research and doesn't
have s c o in it and doesn't have any any
Google in it and it allows people to follow
each other instead of relying on a search
engine
if you want to be a part of that effort at
all you can you can help us we actually
created Pagan. Dev which is a meta language
for parsing
this kind of stuff and we even started like
building out hardware for it so it is their
efforts that if you want I'm kind of doing a
summer stream I can tell everybody probably
laughing at me but but in a week we've got a
number of new people today so I figured it's
worth going through and it will dwindle off
until we all go to bed at somebody else's
surprised the shit out of them so so
searching is a thing yeah if they works is
another one that we're trying to organize
and Kate were says for the associated
Federation knowledge workers otherwise known
as if it works and we really hope to be able
to organize all knowledge workers and and to
reform education by getting more people to
step up and Mentor in addition to the
regular jobs because this education that
were talking about doing it because I was
going
Gmail Swift Terminal absolutely you can use
my Angie must return yet I used to do it all
the time I don't I just throw some mail and
put somebody can also access his e-mail I
just wrote I melt because I used to I do
most of my mail for my phone so so yeah
and so yeah it's a lot of people I find it
when you tell him that that the natural way
and I'm going to do my spill I did the other
day
if you look at the animal kingdom you know
not just humans but all all animals know how
to pass skills between each other they do it
they know how to share that knowledge
between they don't need our fucked-up
education system for it and how did they do
it they Mentor Ave Mentor each other they
meant for each other they demonstrate how to
do something they encourage the other one to
do it right they they they have them do it
repetitively they enlist help and then
eventually they move on and then move out to
Mentor style pod one master Guru and all of
that kind of learning has been around since
way before humans were humans if you believe
in that
it exists everywhere and the one thing that
distinguished Humanity from the rest as we
learn how to write
we learn how to write that's the one thing I
was a whole documentary Isis absolutely
amazing the one thing that lead the humans
to just Skyrocket above all the other rest
of the animal kingdom was our ability to
write and to read it as soon as we did that
our knowledge was not just from you know
pair programming kind of and I always think
of the Monkees teaching each other had to
break open that coconut through pair
programming rather a coconut opening kind of
thing is if I pair programming works
everybody's like oh hey you know I have you
learned all those anything to get ready to
go to all this is the best thing was like I
got to pair with so-and-so right because
it's the natural way it's a human connection
to snatch away are you going to read. You're
going to do that that the practical skills
come about usually through and it's a direct
immediate sharing of that not even if that
person is not present because you can read
about it or you can watch YouTube video some
like that and that's what rocketed humans
way above the rest of the animal kingdom is
because we were able to exchange that
information and and and and really
shake it off you know you guys are busy
that's why we're able to do it might be you
believe that we are made in God's image or
whatever your beliefs are about evolution
about Lucien and the state of learning and
it's it's it's it's pretty easy to observe
and then after Kingdom today how animals
teach each other and in that sense we are
just like that but the point I'm making is
that we are natural Learners in communities
we we learn together we don't we're not
designed to have somebody sit there in the
stage in the top of the in a classroom and
just spew to us stuff that we're going to
listen to We are designed to learn through
Hands-On interaction through loving caring
mentoring and that that's how we're supposed
to work our whole system is totally fucked
up for reasons that I believe are primarily
because of greed but I don't want to get
into that
I don't care about much injury that's a
pretty common topic your I I think the
blockchain engineering definitely needs to
be explored I'm not against exploring the
whole blockchain technology thing I feel
like that I feel like people are just in
genuis when they say they want to solve The
World's problems with blockchain and they
don't even to consider some of the other
simpler solution for that so that kind of
pisses me off because the other all about oh
we're going to save the world that
revolutionizes and feed all the hungry and
everything and I like really and you only
way to do it is through blockchain
technology you know there's lots of other
ways we could consider they don't consider
those ways because deeply deep down they
didn't want their bitcoin price to go up
that bothers me rubs you the wrong way but I
think she needs to be needs to be needs to
be explored as a technology as a technology
whether or not it makes me feel rich and
give a shit it really needs to be explored
as a technology because it's one of the
technologies that allow us to exchange and
and to deception
of other ways to decentralize by the way and
and people to look at them because that's
like the hip cooling right now and it's also
tied to money and so the people that I just
don't like that they say that they're into
it for the money that we save the world
because I'll make the most money off of it
that way
and we'll save the world I just Own It Don't
Lie to ask you do you know what else would
help you know micro loans and other stuff
right there's other things good
and I can talk all night I do talk on it
actually it's kind of how I am I think it's
time for us to raise somebody I really
appreciate you being here and I'm going to
I'm going to I'm going to check out here I
do want to mention that last time you'll see
me I try really hard to change my topic if
you want to be notified when I'm streaming
if I'm sure it's nothing important I will
usually go on stage on the Discord so you
can be notified and Discord that I'm on and
it's reliable if I am
doing something I mean I hopefully I just
giving you a smattering of of the kind of
stuff that we covered here this is the
greatest hits kind of thing right this is
the stuff that we talked about a lot back to
much so there's at least 10 people in here
rolling her eyes are going here we go again
Rob's going to talk about this in this in
this I don't have a discard I don't have any
of the Bots that set up I'm I'm I'm lame I
know so I'm just going to be the robot for
you so here's here's a Spotify here's the
Discord here's my about page and you can you
can look at those things and has been very
ad hoc and I'm partially inebriated but I
just want to say to a lot of times when I'm
here make sure you check the notification
because I go to Great Lengths to set the
notification so you know I'm just fucking
around and Dota 2 or playing Witcher 3 I
don't want anybody to just be disappointed
with me because I'm doing yoga one day
I I stream everything I stream yoga pretty
for a pretty regular I haven't in a while
but I stream yoga and I'm just here you know
Monday good enough and doing all that but
that might be stuff that you're interested
in but I got a Great Lengths to provide a
set of what I called modes that will change
my category and it will change my my summary
these things are in my about page if you
want to read about it oh I fucking love
Witcher on Netflix so sad that he's moving
on did you hear he's leaving
so
ice cream everything's I'm trying to tell
you and just be aware that you might not
want to watch me struggle through kubernetes
for 6 hours you might actually
actually you know you never know that you
can put it on in the siding and learn
something about kubernetes and we take
breaks and stuff like that but but if you if
you want or organized content that's like
beginning to end you know I I I really
ending Leon he's got he's got a really
organized way of going about the learning
that he's doing I really appreciate what
he's doing there I'm not that one pretty
loosey-goosey and May 4th I'm trying really
hard to get every year I get better I get a
little bit better a little bit more
organized and I also the content based on
what's current in professional Exedra Exedra
yeah it's a nice pussy we raid I need a
cuddy buddy you're learning JS ye did you
learn pretty nice streaming live on YouTube
and I'm trying to learn that you recommended
we stream on Twitch I think you just dream
on YouTube or twitch if you got a community
on YouTube you might be one of the ones to
tell me how to do it cuz he thought I was
just showing today is not yet. It's just you
know if you prefer to write in your native
language there's no problem here some
streamers hate that I don't if it's easier
for you to type in your native language I'm
happy to read those as well as far as
streaming on YouTube I tried it I was doing
swimming for a while I stopped it's against
which affiliate policy excetera excetera and
yeah
I'm actually yeah you can even drop the
you can drop that to see I have a I've got
enough people there that I can just go
straight to that the YouTube videos tend to
be more polished occasionally you can be in
the in the studio audience and I will record
a video I like making YouTube videos with
people in my audience at Great risk even
though it's a great risk and we will record
attend 20 minute video will put it up every
Saturday I'm going to start recording all
five hours of those streams and putting
those up as well so people can just put that
on we had people tell me that they started
talking back to the YouTube started trying
to look forward to chat cuz they put the
YouTube video on and they thought they were
in a life community and they forgot that
that it was his life and I like that I like
that I think I think the great disadvantage
of having a community of code Learning
Community like I call it is it is it it's
like you're in this big fucking study hall
together right everybody's like he's going
to bring the pizza next time right. That's
what I love that's what people to help me
Titans go get somebody who should we go
after I really I like I like raiding small
streamers that that you know don't expect it
sometimes like we can sneak up on them so
let's see who's on shall we
and I and I don't know if it's just a silly
red I'm in just chatting right now today so
I normally don't he'll 14k followers and
from one raid that was $2,000 in one night
ohmygod he's taking this that's insane
that is fucking insane
oh thanks Leon appreciate that mostly I
appreciate it because you don't look I love
it I'm not going to lie I like having people
in here I like that it means that there's
more people to help each other I like when a
community grows because that means we could
it's all about helping each other and the
more people there are you know the more
people I tell you my recruiter just like my
phone 2 days ago because he can't find
anybody to do these jobs
he blows up my phone about once a month is
like please do you have anybody I am dying
here I need people that need these skills
are there is a drought of good technologist
out there right now it's like crazy and then
you have the great resignation which
happened last year so that's even leave tech
people you know Tech hiring people even more
desperate so if you learn a minimal set of
good text cuz you can't be lazy you got to
learn it you got to put the time in you got
to create a portfolio that proves your
unique and you are trustworthy and you can
do this and you will get an amazing job you
will I guarantee it I heard you and and
Leona's at the same thing and that's just
that's just so cute socioeconomic factors
I still going on yeah Lourdes Leon so yeah
there's usually there's usually on
twitch.tv /
learn with Leon and I love Leon I love his
approach he has a much different style for
me when I love that I love his style is
different and he has is covering content
which is different than my content which I
also love because that means I can't freeze
me to learn some of the some of the other
stuff I love their many the many things that
they do there there's some people who really
really don't like we had Scotch at for my
community and to those people I'm just going
to say we could just agree to disagree on
that I have I've had a couple people from my
community like really show off and I like
you can you turn it down a bit and maybe
he's just trying to help everybody here you
know and there are a lot of people in it
hacking and infrastructure space who who
don't look at look right now if your web
developer we make jokes about web developers
and they're in good faith we don't mean it
to be bad but will say things like you know
it it's a joke right and we went we would we
would if we were at the pub we would like me
railing on each other
yeah maybe I can grow up and be a web
Builder with its we don't mean it to be mean
it's just it's it's just good nature you
know railing against each other because
we're doing something different right we're
doing I have to put it that way because
otherwise people will hear me say stuff and
then think oh my God Sky such a Nestle and I
am I don't think web development should be
called engineering personally I truly
believe that I don't think your web
development qualifies as legendary with
people really strong as everything is really
fucking awesome so please go there I I I'm
not going to Discount any of that he's been
really awesome oh I know we could go raid
let's go read forbidden VCR this is fucking
hilarious
I forgot to kiss you are so hilarious if you
don't know about forgotten VCR definitely
need to know about it so I'm going to go
read them
what's that
I still don't get it
so let's go let's rage rap music it's just a
fun one
math or engineering absolutely
I never let you know I think you should
learn HTML I read an article today that said
people should stop learning each do not like
what the fuck you should know job is purpose
and I was like what the fuck is that even
mean I seriously was the thing and also said
that you should stop learning seeing you
should learn Ruby instead I was like what
the fuc there is so much bad advice on the
Internet or I'm going to go to ER thank you
so much bye